Five four,
three,
two,
one.
Mike Baker,
ladies,
gentlemen.
And we're live,
ladies and gentlemen.
What's going on buddy?
Yeah,
the usual some wolves over here.
So that's,
that's right.
All right.
Okay.
I left the state of Idaho because,
because we're overrun with wolves,
wolves and,
and uh,
and that's it.
Yeah,
that's all we got was just listening to
a podcast where these guys were talking
about wolves and about how they were
hiking and they found four dead mature
bull elk inside of like a couple miles
stretch that had been torn apart by
wolves.
And they started to freak out.
Well,
I mean,
at two things,
we got this time of year,
we've got a lot of wolves and we've got
a lot of rattlesnakes.
Rattlesnakes are starting to pop up and
make their appearance warm.
Yeah,
exactly.
And there are some seasons where you
can't swing a dead cat without hitting a
rattlesnake.
And of course if you swing a dead cat,
a wolf will show up.
So that's not a good idea in case
anybody's wondering.
I've never been,
I'm going June 30th to boise.
I just announced it tickets today and
it's fantastic.
I'm excited to be there.
But I,
I keep hearing about wolves.
Is that a real issue up there?
Is it not?
It's not exaggerating the century link
arena.
It won't be a problem.
So you should be safe from that.
But uh,
yeah,
bring your gear and you know,
it's,
Idaho is an interesting place because,
you know,
it's a part time legislature,
right?
So,
which is the way I think all states
should operate,
which means everybody goes home to their
jobs.
Well,
if you just look at the top of the
state,
the governor,
Butch Otter,
great guy,
Brad little lieutenant governor,
terrific guy.
They're both ranchers,
right?
So full time,
full time.
Well,
yeah,
basically.
Um,
and uh,
they,
they look at it from a different
problem.
A perspective,
right?
So,
you know,
here in California,
if you say you got a wolf problem,
I mean that,
that racist,
you know,
one perspective and one issue and then
go,
no,
we have a people problem.
So we have a piece that the wolves are
amazing.
Those wolves are so special and in a
place like Idaho or you know,
you get a place like Montana or
somewhere else,
I suppose they look at it differently,
right?
It's a,
it's a working issue that you got it.
You got to sort out,
particularly if you're a rancher or
you're,
you're living off the land,
whatever.
So,
um,
but I,
I tell you what,
boise is going to go crazy when they
find out that he's coming up because you
get,
it's a huge fan base.
They love you up there.
It's all people stop me and want to talk
about,
right.
I keep thinking,
you know,
some said,
I'm sorry for interrupting.
And I think,
okay,
they can ask maybe something about North
Korea,
about Iran or some bigger,
it's not that you're not a big issue,
but then they'll say,
what's Joe like?
And well that's kind of what I say.
You know,
what about Iran,
North Korea,
you fucking kids today,
you don't even care.
Dammit.
Did you know Joe North Korean?
You didn't know that I'm on the seat
tip.
But,
oh,
by the way,
before four,
I disappeared down rabbit holes.
I need to,
I need to say your biggest support.
It your biggest fan probably in the
entire UK,
uh,
is a young fellow named Jack Burden.
I have noticed family forever known this
kid since he
was a baby,
basically.
And going to school with my,
my,
uh,
my daughter.
And he is an enormous fan,
uh,
highly respects what you do.
Uh,
he's getting his master's in physics and
I promised him I'd give him a shout out.
So I've just done the Jack Burton,
Jacques Birdman.
Outstanding Guy by wolves.
Yeah.
They don't have that problem in London,
although that would make some kind of
movie,
I think a,
that's the werewolf out front.
That's right.
Yeah.
It's a great space,
by the way.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I haven't been here since you moved to
give you the full tour.
I didn't give you the,
the gym side.
Did you go to the other side?
I have not.
Not yet.
No.
No sides.
Where the gym is the Cim and the indoor
pool.
We got a lot of stuff here.
It's a great,
uh,
how many,
how big is that?
It looks like about 200,000 square feet.
Now it's 14,
14,000.
But compared to the last studio is a lot
bigger and I got bored with another
place.
You have too little,
you gotta expand where you get your
roller blades out and you can go do laps
or something.
So we got a lot of shit to talk about.
Baker,
there's a lot going on in the world.
What are you scared about?
Oh,
should I be scared about?
Well,
I mean,
people are losing their minds right now
over the past 24 hours because of Iran.
Right?
So what you're hearing as you're hearing
a lot of the,
um,
the,
uh,
the critics of the current president,
and apparently there are some that are
saying,
oh,
he's,
you know,
he's in Chicos closer to a military
conflict with Iran.
Well,
these are the same brainiacs that said
he was entering gets closer to war with
North Korea and they,
everybody was completely wrong on that.
Uh,
I'm not saying that behind me and the
others in the Iranian regime might not,
you know,
decide to become more bellicose.
But,
um,
I think they're,
I think they're looking at it wrong.
I mean there's this idea that,
um,
because there's a couple of parts,
part one is that they're saying,
oh,
look at,
you know,
he doesn't have a plan b implying that
it's either this deal which even our
European allies say is inadequate.
Right?
Uh,
or it's a military conflict.
And that's kind of what the previous
president was,
was all about.
We either get this deal or we're having
a military conflict.
No,
there's other things in the works.
There's other options in that,
in that decision tree.
Um,
and so I think that's,
that's a false premise.
And the other thing when they talk about
it over the past 24 hours anyways,
is that,
well look at this.
This is going to make it harder to get a
deal with,
with Kim Jong.
None from North Korea is cause he's
going to think that we don't,
we don't support our deals.
Well,
I look at a different way.
I think that Kim Jong Un is going to
look at this and think,
uh,
okay,
they're not going to put up with an
inadequate deal.
Right.
So he's gonna look at it and say,
well,
yeah,
because nobody disagrees with the
Iranian deal.
They want to talk about,
they want to talk about how it looked.
The Iranians are complying with it.
Well,
the Iranians are complying with what
they agreed to allow him the deal.
Right.
Which is none of their military sites,
the number of times inspectors have,
have actually gotten on and inspected a
military site,
including Parchin,
the most important military facility in
Iran since that deal was signed in 2015
was zero.
Haven't been there because the Iranians
didn't agree to allow any of those sites
in this deal.
So that's like,
that's like saying,
that's like saying if you're a serial
killer,
you'll allow the police to come in and
search your home,
but you can't go in the basement.
Right.
Not that also he called us,
put their bodies in the basement,
but I,
you know,
I suspect that's the case.
So anyway,
that's,
it's an interesting thing.
I guess I wanted to throw that out there
right off the bat because I think Iran
right now is consuming so much of the
oxygen for,
for people out there.
So people thinking that the reason why
we're backing out of the deals,
because the presence being unreasonable
home,
we're forcing what you're just saying.
It's a shit deal.
Period.
Yeah.
I think the idea that we have to stay in
it because it's better than the
alternative and the alternative,
you know,
being a war is not framing it properly.
I don't think that,
that doesn't make any sense to me.
But I think that the fact that the UK,
the,
the French,
the Germans have all agreed publicly
that it's an inadequate deal.
It needs to be fixed.
That tells you something.
But it also tells you that they have
real strong financial incentives for
continuing to do business in Iran.
They,
and as to Russia and China,
frankly the other signatories.
So you know,
and,
and also here's the other part would be
trump,
you know,
what does it,
now we're 16 or 17 months into trump's
administration.
So it's not like he,
he got into the White House and the next
day he,
you know,
he can the deal,
he's been talking,
but nobody listens to anything.
I'm not,
I'm not a supporter of trump
necessarily.
I mean,
I want the government to work.
So it's not that I'm supporting trump.
I support that.
I want the government to work just like
the previous administration.
I wasn't as supportive Obama,
but hey,
I want it to work.
I like things to happen.
And so he,
you know,
he went out there and there was some
talk about,
look,
let's see if we can't find some way to
get rid of the sunset clause,
some way to rein in their ballistic
missile development program.
Um,
some way,
although it's not going to happen to
reign in all the,
the,
uh,
you know,
the,
the shenanigans,
if you want to call it that,
the Dura engaged in,
in the Middle East.
And that didn't happen.
So I think he,
he,
you know,
took a step that is not as God awful as
his critics would like us to believe.
Well that isn't that,
that's a real problem.
And your phone's going off over there.
A little fella.
Oh,
I'm going to check your watch too.
I got a world we're living in.
I know.
This is good.
Your phone,
you've got to check your watch.
My wife got me this,
uh,
this,
this apple now float.
Now we'll get to it.
It does.
It's waterproof,
I think took to a certain period of
time.
Uh,
but it's,
it,
uh,
it does all sorts of things.
I don't have a clue what it does.
She got it for me so I could check my
heart rate and just,
you know,
for health reasons,
just,
you know,
if I'm,
if I'm out running and working out and
she said,
yeah,
you should have something like that.
Cause I refused to wear a fitbit or
whatever they call it.
What's the difference between a fitbit
and that will this eye,
it's like Dick Tracy.
I could,
if I knew how to do it,
I could talk on my phone.
I could answer it.
It rings.
I have no clue.
It can't be too hard.
I don't think it's that hard.
But I'm just trying it on air.
Yeah.
Okay.
Somebody called me,
somebody give me a shout.
I,
it seems like a great thing.
But honest to God,
the only thing I've used it so far is to
glance at the time and then to check my
heart rate all the other crap on there
and everything happens on it.
Right.
So if I'm using my phone for directions,
I get directions on my watch.
I mean it's a little bit overwhelming so
I'm going to go back to a normal watch I
think.
And,
and if my heart gives out it gives out.
Yeah,
I got this g shock.
It does all kinds of shit.
Never used it once.
I used the time part,
the altimeter and it works as a compass
and all kinds of shit.
I've never compas is good.
I think this is good.
We used to have,
we spent,
we spent a long time,
if this is,
this is how old I'm getting I guess,
but not early training.
Um,
we spent a long time working maps and
compass,
right.
Shooting Asthma's and figuring out where
you're at and trying to and shoot an
asthma.
Yeah.
You know what,
I,
I'll figure figuring out.
You're basically,
I don't want to oversimplify this,
but you're basically triangulating and
figuring out where you are at any given
point in time.
What do you call it,
asthma with eh?
Yeah,
that is a very good question.
And not one that I asked when I was in
the,
in the outfit.
That was one of those people that would
just accept things as they were told to
me.
And uh,
that's why I got along so well.
I never questioned anything,
which is an interesting point.
I don't want to,
I don't want to roam all over this
place,
but today was a confirmation hearings
for Gina Hospital.
And I,
I'll caveat this by saying I'm a big
supporter of hers.
I think she's an outstanding choice for
this.
She's the new head of the CIA,
the new director designate for the CIA.
And so today she went up on Capitol
Hill.
I had,
uh,
open and uh,
then subsequently closed door session
with the senators and some of the
senators.
The reason I bring this up is because a
handful of the senators were asking her
and seem to focused on saying,
well,
you know,
how,
when would this rendition program,
they rendition and interrogation
program,
how did you feel about it?
What morally,
what,
you know,
did you have any quandary is what we,
we know that you,
you,
you know,
the agency was doing what was allowed
within the Department of Justice.
Uh,
because the office of legal counsel was
directing that from the Department of
Justice for that program all those years
ago.
And lots of subsequently changed.
But at the time they didn't want to
necessarily talk about that cause I
don't think they wanted to highlight the
fact that the doj had said this is what
is able to be done.
Um,
so instead they focused on how did you
feel?
And I guess the reason I bring it up is
because when I was in the outfit,
I'm not a deep thinker,
right?
So I never sort of around and thought to
myself,
how do I feel about this?
So I'm going to give it a moment,
right?
I mean,
no matter what we were doing,
it never occurred to me to sit there and
question it.
You know,
as long as we knew what we were doing
was proper and legal and was pursued of
tasking from,
from,
uh,
national security concerns,
then yeah.
And I don't think you want you your
military or your Intel service.
I don't think you want everybody out
there at the pointy edge of the spear,
you know,
saying,
well,
I'm going to do things based on how I
feel about it in the moment.
And it just seemed like a strange line
of questioning,
questioning who is responsible for that?
Let me think.
They were actually,
uh,
there were,
there were three or four.
Yeah.
Senator Reed and,
and,
uh,
so trial Democrats obviously trying to
understand well,
so what they did then was different than
what is legal today.
Is that the case?
Uh,
yes,
exactly.
So the DOJ,
um,
in,
in the wake of nine 11,
I mean,
there's so much here.
in the wake of nine 11,
you think about the context.
Most people,
you know,
young people don't even know what it
feels like.
Right?
I mean,
you know,
and other people have forgotten or they
just tired of it all and they don't want
to think about it.
But in the wake of nine 11,
there was a,
um,
there was a feeling there was a sense,
right,
that it was going to happen again.
And there certainly was evidence and
there was,
there was a very large effort here to
try to ensure that we protect American
lives.
So the DOJ was issuing a very clear
guidance on what could and could not be
done for the rendition and interrogation
program.
And that guidance was provided to the
general counsel at the agency that was
then disseminated to personnel out in
the field and tell,
tell people.
So if they're just listening to us for
the first time,
what you used to do for the CIA,
so they understand that you're coming
from a position of you,
you actually understand this stuff.
Uh,
yeah.
I,
I was in the Operations Directorate,
so the agency is made up of essentially
they'd change the name sometimes,
but four directorates.
So you have operations,
you have intelligence,
which is all the smart people that
reports,
or officers or sorry,
the analysts,
you have science and technology,
which is where they develop all the
amazing gear that comes out of the
agency,
a lot of which then ends up in the
commercial sector.
So if anybody's walking around with a
defibrillator,
that battery technology came out of s
and t research,
drones,
satellite technology,
um,
uh,
youtube stealth program,
Youtube,
you know,
plain was,
was developed out of and run out of the
agency.
So incredible things to come out of
there.
And then admin.
But I was in the Operations Directorate
and worked on everything from counter
narcotics operations to
counterinsurgency operations and,
and,
and then obviously counter terrorism
operations.
So I guess the point is that,
I mean there's,
there's something here.
I,
I'm not quite sure how to explain it,
but there's an interesting point that I
think I've been pondering,
which is that listening to the hearing
today and listening to the way that the
senators,
the Democratic senators who were looking
to kind of make this the key issue,
um,
there's,
there's a,
a sense of we're not putting it in
context of the time and the national
mood.
And that's a dangerous thing because the
laws were different than they are now.
And they were different.
And what that means is that because of
in the wake of nine 11,
and I don't want to say that that values
change,
um,
but I think that they do in the sense of
what people are willing to,
uh,
to do.
And whether you're talking about,
okay,
we're willing to have a rendition
interrogation program in the wake of
nine 11.
Now we're not,
of course.
And uh,
so I think it's,
anyway,
I think there's a,
there's a danger to that line of
questioning where they kept talking
about how,
how did it,
how did you feel about it?
And it's not you,
you,
you're,
you're there.
They're mixing this and I'm not eloquent
enough to explain it,
but I found it fascinating that that was
a question they wanted to focus on.
I think there's a real danger to people
or for people that don't have any
experience in the actual war and,
or really understand combat or really
understand what can happen and what can
go wrong in talking about it with the
same sort of language that you would use
to describe office politics.
Yes.
I they got to say that's what damn it.
That's what I was trying to say.
You know,
like how you feel,
how do you feel about this?
We don't want a bad work environment.
Should we torture right now.
We want to save lives,
but we don't want this guy to feel bad.
We don't want him to feel bad.
And I mean,
look,
there was actually this,
this is,
some people were entertaining the idea
that,
you know,
Khaleed Sheikh Mohammed would come out
and talk to the senators.
Uh,
you know,
as you're going through this
confirmation process about what his
feelings,
we'll clean check.
Muhammad was a mastermind of nine 11 and
he actually requested to talk about her
right.
And about,
about his [inaudible] just wanted to
reflect on the,
had the whole,
you know,
from his perspective and isn't he still
locked up?
He shown Guantanamo Bay.
Yeah.
You know,
God forbid he should rot in jail,
but um,
you know,
I think it's,
it's kind of where we,
that's sort of where we've come to.
And I think in part,
again,
because there's distance,
right?
There's two months.
And so anyway,
I,
she showed again,
she should be confirmed.
Um,
the,
the whole rendition interrogation
program was reviewed at Nauseum,
thousands of pages written.
And interestingly enough,
a lot of the people up there on the hill
right now in this confirmation process,
the senators who are saying that they
need to know more,
but the same ones who were there before.
So theoretically,
either they didn't read all the material
that was given to them about this,
where they've forgotten it,
where there,
you know,
or in reality this is more about trump
than it is about her,
which I don't want to be shocking anyone
by saying that perhaps there's political
grandstanding going on,
but she is eminently qualified and it
happened.
No,
it wouldn't happen up there.
Not In America,
maybe somewhere else,
not here.
So anyway,
you support her.
He thinks she's an excellent choice and
look seven,
seven operational tours,
uh,
several management positions.
And I guess at the end of the day it
comes down to,
um,
I would rather have somebody who's gone
through that experience.
She played a small role.
She was not as a senior person by the
way.
John Brennan was far more senior in the
organization at the time of that program
being run.
And he was confirmed as President
Obama's director.
Um,
so maybe the senators have a different
standard for a female candidate.
I don't know.
But do you think it's down or anything?
It's maybe more time since nine,
11.
You know,
obviously Obama came into office,
it was not that long after nine 11,
there was still,
you know,
seven years later still thoughts in
people's mind about it.
Well,
interesting enough,
I mean that was in 2013 when he was
confirmed,
but in 2009 he was,
they wanted to confirm it or they wanted
to bring him up as the appointee for the
director of the CIA.
Again,
it would have been president Obama's
first term,
but they decided not to because for the
reason that they thought,
well maybe it's too close to after the,
and they didn't want to go through the
heartburn of having this process.
So instead they brought him into the
White House.
He became assistant to the president and
deputy national security dude for
counter terrorism.
And then four years later they brought
him in as a,
you know,
then confirmed him as the director for
the CIA.
So,
um,
I guess,
and he has now come out in support of
Gina Hospital,
the new director designate.
So I think she will get there as she
should.
The focus should be going forward.
She's been very clear about,
we're not revisiting the old,
the old days of,
of a rendition interrogation.
It's not going to happen.
And she's been very clear about that and
including today during the hearing.
So hopefully,
hopefully it'll,
it'll,
it'll get done because it's,
it would be nice to think the senators
would do their job and choose somebody
who's appropriate for the job.
Well,
it's just,
it's strange who gets to choose and who
doesn't get to choose who runs an
organization like the CIA and whether or
not they have an actual understanding of
what goes on behind the scenes.
Yeah.
That's a really good,
it's a good point because some of the
questions today from some of the
senators made you believe that perhaps
they don't really do that.
I don't want,
I don't want to be Glib,
you know,
look,
they all sit on the committees.
They theoretically are,
are,
are privy to all this information.
There is a very well worn path that goes
from lying light where the agency
headquarters is based up to Capitol Hill
from briefers going back and forth and
back and forth and discussing programs.
And that,
you know,
the classified material,
but these people,
that gang of eight,
that people that are the minority
majority leaders,
the heads of the committees,
the Intel committees,
uh,
they're all privy to this information
and they were all privy to the
information about the rendition program
and the interrogation program.
And they all knew about it.
There were no objections raised at that
time.
2000,
two,
2003.
So these people all knew about it.
So maybe those senators are asking her
how she feels about it now maybe they
should turn around and look in the
mirror and ask themselves how they feel
about it,
but they're not going to do that.
So anyway,
that and I,
enough set,
she's eminently qualified should happen.
Uh,
because we've got big issues.
We got it wrong.
We've got North Korea,
we've got the dealings with China in the
south and the South Pacific.
We got issues with Russia.
We had a lot of things going on.
What I really wanted to ask you about,
cause we've been discussing this and I
don't really understand it.
Um,
it was about wowway that a Chinese
company,
electronics company,
they make these tick ass phones and the
State Department has said,
please do not buy them.
Yes.
Yeah.
Along with cte and other corporation,
um,
if you start from the premise that the
China is the number one perpetrator of
economic espionage and theft of
intellectual property,
uh,
and also by the way,
the number one perpetrator out there of
cyber shenanigans,
you know,
activity in cyberspace
because so bad with that theft of
intellectual property that they have
fake apple stores over in China with all
fake apple stuff.
Yes.
Fake apple laptops,
fake apple phones,
everything fake.
The labels look identical.
None of it is actually apple products.
And it all works frankly as well.
Does this,
yeah,
it's all good stuff.
Enough.
Um,
you know,
uh,
I would say,
um,
it,
yeah,
it's astounding.
And so the reason why they're,
they're raising the alarm with Huawei
and zte is because of the voracious
appetite of the Chinese government and
the commercial sector for information.
And it's a little bit like shutting the
door after the horse is headed down the
hill because we're late to the game.
They've been doing this for years and
years and years.
They've been oddly enough of it,
you know,
a lot of our military gear have parts in
a manufacturing in China.
Right.
And so,
you know,
if we should have been raising the
concern about this and talking with
China and trying to come to terms with
this issue years ago,
I mean we get,
we're,
we're trying to have that conversation
with them now and up on Capitol Hill,
you know,
the,
the congress is trying to enact
legislation,
kind of like this quality thing.
They're doing it in a clumsy fashion.
But the overriding principle is correct
in that China made some decisions years
ago,
that they were going to become a major
power in the world in a certain
timeframe.
And to do that,
by definition,
you got to compress your research and
development time.
Right.
And as one way to do that.
And essentially,
and that's the steal information to
acquire information if I want to be
diplomatic about it.
And that's what they've done.
Japan came out of World War II and their
idea was we're going to become a major
power through manufacturing.
So they did,
they built up their manufacturing base
and created this,
uh,
this,
this amazing result.
China decided we're going to skip the R
and d for the most part.
Um,
and all of that entails the cost and
time involved.
And they've,
they're very adept at it.
They,
they throw an enormous amount of
resource out there into hoovering up
everything,
not just from us but from everybody.
And using that to advance their goals.
They have no firewall between their
Intel service and the PLA,
military intelligence and others and
their commercial sector.
So,
you know,
not only are they,
they are to protect national security,
they're there to promote,
uh,
the commercial side of,
of China.
Uh,
and that's why it's so important.
And so that's why they're there talking
about Huawei,
uh,
because of the potential for them to,
use their,
uh,
their reach,
to further their desire for information.
Whatever it may be.
They'll hoover it up and then decide
whether it's useful or not.
But they have the resource to do that as
opposed to,
you know,
a smaller country that maybe doesn't
have the resource and is much more
targeted and focused on their Intel
collection.
Are there efforts to gather information?
So that's,
that's sort of the,
you know,
that was a wordy explanation.
No,
but it makes sense.
And it's a,
when I read it,
I read a bunch of tech articles where
people were questioning whether or not
it's even possible for while way to be
using those phones to spy on people.
But then there was some other articles
where while we was being charged with a,
what was it again,
they were using,
there were,
there were selling illegal technology to
Iran.
There was,
there was something.
They were,
they were breaking the sanctions,
I think.
Yeah,
they were,
no,
I'm saying I say that correct.
Yeah,
there were.
But is that what,
so they were,
they were selling things to Iran and
this was a big part of it,
that they were,
what the tech people were saying they
were incredulous here.
Walway under is that you again,
you son of a bitch.
Jesus Christ.
I've turned this thing off to.
I don't understand why it keeps going.
You know what?
I been dope.
I would,
I would put it on airplane mode,
but I don't have a clue how to put it on
the swipe up from the bottom.
Swipe up from the bottom.
Okay.
Everybody get your phones or your watch
is ringing?
Watch out.
I feel like Dick Tracy,
it really does feel like Dick Tracy when
we were kids.
The idea of talking on your phone be so
ridiculous.
Like what?
That's never going to happen.
You've got your password on that.
Oh Christ.
You take it off the path or it comes on
immediately.
Oh really?
So you just take it down.
No,
that's a dial tone.
That's set.
It's a keyboard.
Yeah.
I don't even know.
I can't right now.
People to think and really that guy
worked like I worked at the CIA.
Let's listen to him.
It's perfect.
Would you call?
Hopefully they,
I don't know.
It's hilarious because you're talking
about technology and then this happens.
So we're talking about whether or not we
should be worried about walway and you
can't even figure out how to use your
fucker.
That's,
that's perfectly understand.
But anybody that knows me knows that
that's the case because,
I mean,
to be fair,
back in the old days I,
we encompasses and maps,
but even when we started developing new
technology and cure it,
quite frankly,
if you've got to go out and do anything,
if first thing you do is throw
everything away that's got a battery in
it.
And so we weren't necessarily getting
dumb it down because you assumed
something's gonna go wrong.
And usually it does.
And usually it's based on kit,
on gear.
And so,
yeah,
I never really became very adept at it.
We've got,
we've got a,
I got a,
there's three little boys scooter sluggo
on and,
and I got delirious names and they're,
they're hilarious.
It's great kids.
But we got a,
we got a gaming system and I'm trying to
remember what the hell,
xbox or playstation,
uh,
xbox,
xbox and uh,
cause my youngest mugsy,
he's,
uh,
he's always six.
And so he still says,
yeah,
he's,
he's thrilled or pronounces words,
right?
So it's x,
x patch and it's really cute.
I can't do it.
It doesn't,
it sounds stupid when I do it.
What he does,
it's enormously cute.
So we get to sing and I'll sit there
with them and try to play like NBA Two k
or something and it just doesn't work.
It's not intuitive to me.
There's nothing that's intuitive about
it.
Know how to find Shit and press the
right button.
They're not,
they just assume they're going to get it
online.
Yeah.
Hidden characters by moving the joystick
Dick.
A funny way.
Yeah.
Mugs.
He talks to the Lebron James directly.
Apparently they communicate through
x-box now.
There you go.
The tech people that are skeptical,
what they're saying is that if walway
really did have something in their
phones that allow them to spy on people,
you'd be able to find it and the tech
guys would find it.
Do you buy that?
Um,
here,
here's what I would say about that is
that,
um,
I'm sure,
yeah,
there's obviously a lot of very smart
tech guys and within a diligence for all
your information and security needs,
we have some very smart tech people,
but when you're talking about the
Chinese state and the resources and
capabilities that that entails,
uh,
yes.
If you're,
if you're saying that NSA could possibly
detect this,
but if you're talking about just
dispersing kid out into the marketplace
and the way that that thing gets spread
and disseminated and inserted into
companies and,
and then potentially allow us points of
access into these businesses.
And again,
it doesn't matter,
it's,
it's not like they just have to go after
ibm or Raytheon or something.
They're going after everything because
it potentially is all of interest to
them.
So their ideas to just steal as much
technology and as much intellectual
properties they can and recreate it over
China.
That has been the,
the plan.
I don't want to keep,
I don't want to,
you know,
uh,
demonize an entire nation,
but they have proven themselves
enormously adapted doing this and
they've,
they,
and not that others don't.
Right.
Russia does the same thing.
I'll have a variety of others,
you know,
that,
even,
you know,
a lot of our allies,
everybody if to the degree that they
have the resources and the motivation
and they consider it an issue related to
national security,
whatever it might be,
they're willing to do it.
They're willing to try.
So it is,
uh,
it is interesting.
But yeah,
the,
the hallway thing and the zte again,
I think the roll out of that con a
concern and the roll out of sort of
trying to provide guidance has been a
little clumsy.
So one,
one thing that was speculation was that
people didn't have to worry about the
phones,
but what is essentially they're trying
to do is cripple the company financially
and not allow them to get a foothold in
America because they're the third
largest cell phone manufacturer in the
world.
Number one,
apple,
number two,
Samsung,
they're number three.
But in America,
no one knows who they are.
And so the idea is what they're trying
to do is make sure that the Chinese
government doesn't get a foothold in
this company,
in this country where those companies
are wowway the company while way becomes
a,
a popular brand for people to buy.
And that would allow them,
even if they didn't have any spy device
on this phone,
it would allow them to get other devices
into people's homes that could
potentially spy on them and then more
importantly,
get into companies,
right.
And spying the companies.
And this was one of the pieces of
speculation that I read about was that
they had certain servers that were
sending an exorbitant amount of
information,
uh,
out and they were trying to figure out
what was going on with them and that
there's like an excessive amount of
information that was data that was
leaving the servers versus coming in and
they're like,
this really seems like some fucked up
Shit's going on with this.
Right.
[inaudible] first of all,
who always already present here in the
country,
they manufacture a lot of things besides
phones.
And so they've already got a pretty big
footprint in this country and,
and with our allies as well.
Um,
so I think it's smart to consider the
nature of a particular regime or
government,
you know,
when you're talking about the potential
for their products to enter into the
commercial sector where they may have
access,
because if,
if they've shown a pattern of activity
for acquiring intellectual property,
which is again,
a very delicate way to put it,
then I don't think it's a stretch to say
we should be concerned by their efforts
to put,
um,
communications gear,
even if it seems pedestrian at the
outset,
uh,
into the marketplace.
So I,
I'm not sure that I'm,
I'm buying the idea that it's some
nefarious plan to shut out Huawei so
that either they don't get a foothold in
the phone business.
Um,
no,
and I say that because I had been,
you know,
30 years I've been dealing with a
Chinese,
uh,
in terms of their,
efforts to acquire information posted on
the government and commercial side of
things.
So,
uh,
I come at it from a very cynical point
of view,
a much like I did with the Iranian issue
and,
and the likelihood that they have not
been living up to,
you know,
they're,
they're part of the bargain and people
will say,
well,
again,
I go back to the same thing.
Well,
boy,
boy them inspecting and they've been
complying with all of that.
Well,
yeah,
you know,
there's limited amount of inspection
that we have to their civilian sites and
[inaudible] it's not a secret,
you know,
at this point,
it shouldn't be a secret that again,
we have no access to their military
facilities.
So,
um,
I,
I tend to look at things in that view
and I,
I,
if I see a pattern of activity,
uh,
I'm,
I'm very reluctant to think they're
somehow going to stop that pattern of
activity for whatever reason.
So again,
North Korea,
same thing.
The problem with all of this,
North Korea,
Iran,
Syria,
and chemical weapons.
The problem with all of that,
I realize I'm kind of jumping around and
I've just,
uh,
walway's over here,
but is,
uh,
the verification.
It's always the week Lincoln,
any type of agreement related to a
containing a weapons program is
verification.
And we know that we,
you know,
it's,
it's something we should know anyway.
We keep,
we seem to keep forgetting it.
So,
uh,
unless we can lock that down with the
North Koreans,
then,
you know,
a deal with them or a deal with the
Iranians or deal with a Syrians over
their chemical weapons efforts.
And it's,
it's,
it's not worth anything.
So that's,
that's where the focus has to be.
And for whatever reason,
the previous administration was keen to
get this deal done and they were willing
to set aside this issue of all the
military sites set aside the issue of
ballistic missiles.
And by the way,
that deal that president has just
scuttled,
did nothing to impact or effect or tamp
down or moderate their behavior.
They've got more influenced in the
Middle East and they've had ever before,
they're engaged in more,
uh,
activity related to,
you know,
uh,
the countries in the Middle East against
our interests other than they have been
in,
in decades.
So that,
that all by itself should tell us,
well,
you know,
I'm not saying that they're using all
the money.
We gave them to a support,
you know,
uh,
actions against our interest by
Hezbollah or by a revolutionary guard or
others.
But they are.
And so,
you know,
I,
again,
I don't have a lot of angst over the
idea that we,
we step away from the deal for a period
of time.
Maybe we can come up with something
better and we should,
we should always keep the mock a
diplomacy open,
always have a channel of communications
that's important.
Keep doing that,
but be pragmatic and realistic about
what you got.
And right now we don't,
we don't have that much and don't buy
walway phones.
Don't.
Wow.
Interesting that actually,
Kayla,
I know they make a great father,
but that came up in that and the CIA
confirmation hearing.
Oh really?
Yeah.
They literally said,
um,
I forget which senator it was asked Gina
Hospital about Huawei and zte and um,
I don't know where they were going with
it,
but then it devolved into just trying to
get us all those Senate confirmation
questions do,
it just comes at,
you know,
the senator saying,
well,
I just want a yes or a no answer.
You know,
like,
wait a minute,
why don't you want some detail?
But,
so they say yes or no.
Would you buy Huawei in Chino Hospital?
Was like,
well,
no,
I wouldn't buy a hallway fault.
Okay,
there's your answer.
So,
but I'm sure it left a lot of people
wondering and scratching their heads and
go,
what are they talking about Chinese
phones for it?
That's a weird thing to ask someone yes
or a no.
It seems like it was pretty complex
situation.
Yeah.
Are you,
uh,
are we gonna take care of North Korea?
Yes or no?
I,
you know what I mean?
Well,
I,
you know,
it,
it becomes a bit of a side show and it's
a format as well.
Any confirmation hearing is,
you know,
five minutes for each senator and he
can't,
you know,
they spend three minutes making a
statement,
you know,
that they can then send back and sound
clips to their constituents.
Uh,
maybe they get a question in and,
and it kind of goes from there.
So it's,
you don't really learn much,
which is fine.
You know,
they learned a lot in the closed door
sessions and we rely on the senators to
make decisions when it's classified
information on behalf of the people they
represent.
So that's how it's supposed to work.
Yeah.
What do I know?
I always like to finish my sentences
with what do I know when my wife always
says,
what are you talking?
Why do you do that?
What are you leaving the impression that
you don't know anything?
People are gonna say,
well,
why is he off the hook a little bit when
we get out of here?
What do I know it is what it is?
Thinking about what I said,
what the fuck do I know?
It's like running up the flag pole to
salutes.
What are you most concerned with?
If you look at all the international
stuff that's going on.
Yeah,
that's a really good question.
Um,
is there one thing that you don't think
people are looking at?
Well,
you know,
I give people a,
a lot of credit.
I think people are a lot more um,
engaged then sometimes I think the media
gives them credit for,
uh,
I mean listen to conversations I have
when people want to talk about something
other than Joe Rogan,
I get the impression that they are
paying attention to what's happening out
there.
Um,
and I,
yeah,
Iran.
Is it a big deal?
Well it is a big deal but it's a
regional issue.
Um,
and I think there is a,
uh,
a way we're going to get some success
here.
I think it actually is going to work out
to our benefit.
I'm not buying the doomsayers you say
it's,
it's all heading to a conflict,
so I'm not looking at that one.
You know,
nothing really stands out.
I guess if you said,
what's the biggest concern from a
security perspective to the,
to the country,
it would be the same thing.
It's been last year and the year before.
And for a number of years,
which is the frailty of our
infrastructure and its susceptibility to
either cyber attack or physical attack.
And that's the power grid power net,
all of that.
The banking system and water,
Russian submarines camped out over the
internet lines and the ocean.
I know,
which sounds like a cold war movie.
Right.
But it happens.
I mean,
the Russians,
the Russians never thought there was a
peace dividend from the end of the Cold
War.
They never thought the Cold War ended.
And we,
we all act surprised that Putin was
engaged in meddling in the 2016
election.
Of course he was.
They've been through it that forever.
So,
and we have to them as well.
Right?
Oh,
I don't know about that.
Wow.
Maybe from a defensive point of,
sure.
We're just looking out for our own.
Here's what I would say about that is,
um,
and again,
everybody speaks from their own
experience.
People have their own perspective.
My perspective is based on what I've
seen,
uh,
in,
in a lot of places around this planet.
Uh,
we better hope we do it and we've been
hope we do it well because it's a very
aggressive world out there.
And so when people kind of roll our eyes
and go,
Oh wow,
we do it as well,
you know,
so we kind of like dismissing the whole
activity.
I guess my point is,
yeah,
I get what you're saying.
You know?
Okay.
We,
you know,
I'm not saying it from a self righteous
point that the Chinese are very good at
acquiring an intellectual property or
I'm not saying it from self righteous
points.
The Russians had been meddling in our
elections.
I'm just saying that's the way it is.
You better hope we do it very,
very well.
That's my argument for people that are
super progressive and really
bro,
when the,
when it comes to these conversations,
I always say,
all right,
if the world is the way it's described,
if China really is constantly meddling,
if Russia is really actively trying to
sabotage our elections,
if I ran is really doing what the,
what should we do?
You don't think that we should be
involved in,
in meddling,
you don't think should be involved in
manipulating or monitoring or making
sure that our interest are safe or that
we're not going to get attacked.
The idea that we're never going to get
attacked,
you know,
no one's going to get attacked.
That doesn't even,
well,
you look at human history,
that is completely preposterous.
The inside of the,
all the tax and all wars going to
somehow or another stop because you eat
vegan.
Right?
That's fucking crazy.
I mean,
that's a crazy way to look at the world.
And that leaves you incredibly
vulnerable to attack.
No,
it does.
It does it.
But that,
but you're right,
I hadn't thought about it,
but,
but that is this notion that if we,
if we just,
we have to speak to our better angels.
You know Jesus.
Well that's great because nobody else is
going to write.
Every other nation acts in its own best
interest.
And we're the ones who seem to always
apologize for it,
but we better hope that we do because it
is a chaotic,
messy,
aggressive place out there.
And you may want it to be different,
but it's not.
And it's kind of like that,
that questioning today and the CIA
designate confirmation hearing.
How do you feel about it?
Well,
at the end of the day,
it doesn't matter how you feel about it.
What are the laws on the books?
Follow those laws,
you know,
protecting American interests and in
national security.
And if you don't feel good about it,
then leave and go do something else.
But this idea that somehow we're all
gonna.
I mean,
could you imagine,
you know,
a combat gate out there and half of them
decide,
well,
I mean,
I don't really feel good about this
particular action.
You know,
maybe we should stay back it.
That's not how the world works.
So I know,
I dunno.
Hey,
it'd be great if we all could be better
people,
isn't it?
Again,
we're talking to,
and you know,
this is coming from a person that has an
experienced combat,
but we're,
we're talking about a bunch of people
that really don't understand and really
haven't seen things that you've seen or
seen.
The things that the military is seen and
they're talking about the world in this
sort of idealized rose colored glasses
view of things that's not accurate.
And so their,
their version of what America should do
is based on,
it's based on ignorance in this idea
that we don't need intelligence,
we don't need a military.
We don't need a presence in all these
other countries.
I,
yeah,
I just don't,
I don't buy that.
I don't think that makes sense when you
look at all the different conflicts that
are going on in the world.
Yeah,
I know,
I agree.
I think that there is a,
there's an element out there that says
if we just take her on as an example,
um,
in obs spoken with people who,
who honestly seemed to believe that in
part because the previous,
I mean now former secretary carries out
their public aid and abet President
Obama's out there,
but they're all saying,
well,
but the Iranians have been complying.
So it's,
you know,
they're implying that it's our fault.
It's our fault for backing out of this.
It's our fault that somehow that the
Iranians have been cheating on the
missile sanctions.
Look,
the,
the UN even agreed in it at the end of
2014 that in just in October of that
year,
the Iranians had been busting a
agreements related to their ballistic
missiles and their development.
And we signed that agreement a few
months later,
three months later.
Right.
Um,
it happens,
you know,
no matter what you may want to think.
Uh,
it is a,
it's a,
it's a messy place at the,
I would love it to be different.
I would love everybody to get along and
he would be great.
Think what we could do if we didn't have
a defense budget and we can all be on,
be happy.
Yeah,
it'd be,
it'd be wonderful,
but flowers everywhere.
Oh my God.
And UNICORNS.
Well maybe not unicorns.
I guess that physically they're just
sort of real.
You can make one now.
All the money that you don't spend on
war.
That's right.
I could probably have one pop out of my
watch if I knew how to work it.
I'm impressed.
I know the passcode.
I was about to actually do the passcode
and say it out loud.
Sometimes you ever find yourself doing
that?
Like when you're typing a number,
I was about to do that here when I was
putting in my passcode anyway.
Well,
people are always going to have an
idealized version of the world,
especially,
especially with they own experience it
themselves.
But I think that,
uh,
for the most part,
when people think of intelligence
community,
so thinking about the CIA or the FBI,
generally for whatever reason in
America,
you get a negative response.
People don't think about it in terms of
something that's necessary and
beneficial and really a cornerstone of
the protection of the people in this
country.
They don't think of it that way.
No,
I think that's been a tradition.
Um,
you could go back to,
we'll work to the end of World War II,
um,
oss,
which was the,
the founding organization that then
became later on the CIA,
uh,
amazing people involved in,
in oss and basically,
um,
they,
what they did during the war,
it was incredible.
So anyway,
but they do this.
And while Bill Donald Donovan was the
head of Oss.
So imagine all these dedicated people
dropping in behind enemy lines,
both in the European and Japanese
theater and engaged in all this activity
for the years that it took to win that
war.
And we got out of the war,
we finished and I,
I'm assuming most people listening know
how that ended.
And Truman literally just kind of writes
a little note to Bill Donovan.
I've seen the note and it says,
you know,
Bill,
hey,
great job,
thanks so much.
Uh,
wrapping it up.
You know,
all the best good luck in the future.
And they shut down Oss,
right?
They don't need it anymore.
They didn't need the Intel service
because we won the war and things are
gunna be looking pretty good.
Well,
about a year later,
uh,
you know,
they,
they got the band back together because
what was happening and the Soviets
running,
you know,
all over the place and it was the cold
war and the Soviets had no intention of
being benign and living in a community
of nations.
And so suddenly they got the band back
and said,
let's,
okay.
So that's when the CIA was created in
1947,
uh,
at the end of the Cold War,
not that long ago.
Um,
although it seems like ancient history
now,
there were a lot of serious people in
Washington dc at when the wall fell,
who basically said,
let's wrap up the age so we don't need
the CIA anymore.
So there's this pattern of,
you know,
people want and that's good back.
People want to think the best.
And I,
that's a good thing.
I mean,
Americans tend to be,
whether it's ideological or,
or naive or optimistic,
whatever it is,
that's a good thing.
Right?
But it,
it,
it butts up against the reality of how
the world actually works.
Well,
because in America,
things are pretty good.
I mean,
yeah,
they're about as good as it gets in the
world when you wander around America for
a,
as a large nation as this is,
things are pretty God damn good for the
most part.
Yeah.
And I think that's part of the problem
is that these people,
they're not traveling to these war zones
and not experiencing,
I've talked to so many people that have
been overseas and been to these places
of conflict and they come out with an a
dark view of what is possible if you're
in the wrong place on the planet.
Yeah.
What people can do to each other is a
uh,
yeah,
it,
it can get messy.
Um,
but I think there would be value if
somehow we could enact some program
where everybody had to spend a couple of
years in service of some sort of
military service or oversee service.
I know we had the peace corps and all of
that,
but,
you know,
and,
and high school kids say,
wow,
I went to Bermuda and I built a house
for a week.
And so I got my international
experience.
That's better than nothing.
It's better than nothing.
But I mean,
I think something that would would mean
people would have a little more skin in
the game and,
and,
uh,
but you're right.
I mean,
you go to some of these places.
Fourth and fifth world countries.
And uh,
and you do realize,
and I'm an I,
you know,
people roll their eyes,
but I damn it,
this is the best country in the world.
And I say that repeatedly and I believe
it firmly,
we make mistakes.
There's no doubt about it.
But we tend to course correct.
We try,
sometimes it takes a little bit longer.
Uh,
we,
no matter what administration is there,
we try to do the right thing.
And so when people talk about,
you know,
us just stepping off and,
and not worrying about our place in the
world,
uh,
you know,
someone's going to try to take that
position on the ladder and it's not
going to be as benign as,
as we tend to be.
Not always.
Again,
again,
I realize we make mistakes.
That's fine.
Okay,
fine.
I'm not going to self flagellate over
it,
but you know,
still we do a pretty damn good job.
We tried to be the moral authority of
the world or the moral compass at least.
I mean,
that's the thought process behind it for
the most part.
Yeah.
That's the thought process.
And,
and,
you know,
sometimes,
again,
it's a human endeavor so it's not going
to work all the time.
Don't you think that people are more
open to this idea that it's necessary
now because of the Russian situation and
because of understanding the,
the amount of power that Putin wheels
and the way he has just really ultimate
control over that part of the world.
And he really does.
I mean,
you could drone on all you want about
democratic elections,
but we all know that's horse shit.
I mean,
he fucking kills anybody over there.
That's a legitimate threat.
Kills anybody over there.
Journalists over there.
I mean,
look,
they just,
they tried to scribble and his daughter
you'll,
yes,
she was,
she was collateral damage.
But uh,
put some shit on a door knob.
Yeah,
they touched with their hands.
I nerve agent them and put them in the
hospital.
And who knows if they're even going to
recover from that.
I mean,
think about it.
She's,
she's out of the hospital now.
She's doing good.
He's doing a little bit better.
Uh,
but I mean,
think about what that entails as an
operation.
Right.
Not that they haven't,
they,
they've been doing this since they
killed,
what's his name?
Trotsky in Mexico.
Right.
I mean they,
this is what they do.
But yeah.
Markov liftfund ankle,
Alexander Olympia and ankle,
they killed him with a polonium and that
was just a handful of years ago.
So they go after Sergei,
he's living in a small,
relatively small quiet,
you know,
I'm British town,
Salisbury.
And so that requires him to surveil
Sergei.
They got to get,
you know,
cause you always had to do that.
You gotta do some operation like this.
You gotta know what you're getting into
it.
You got to figure out how you're going
to do it.
And so there's a lot of,
you got to front load all that work.
Right.
And so they're doing all this
surveillance.
They're figuring out what their
operational game plan's going to be.
You know,
this is in the UK and their whole point
of the exercise is to teach other people
don't,
don't betray us.
Right.
And,
and,
uh,
so,
you know,
then they put this on a door,
not,
they didn't care who else touch said
Nah,
it wasn't like they could,
they could guarantee that,
you know,
the postman and a variety of visitors
weren't going to come through the door.
So they really,
they really don't care.
Um,
yeah,
he is,
uh,
he is definitely,
he's a,
he's an old school kgb,
very easy cat to understand,
you know,
and we've always kind of acted like,
we don't get it or somehow he's going to
change his stripes.
He's never going to change his stripes
and he's going to always act in what he
believes to be the best interest of what
he would like to believe.
Is that still the former Soviet Union
and Gary
far off was talking about him and you
know,
he's a vocal critic of Putin.
And he was saying that if you look into
all the different companies that they've
confiscated and acquired,
and you know,
th th th this what they do,
like if they have a political enemy,
they essentially just take over their
company and charge them with some sort
of a crime and throw him in jail.
And they do,
they do this too.
Billionaires,
right?
Kowski he spent years in jail and um,
and his,
his mistake was,
uh,
his mistake was he started getting
political aspirations.
And so the deal has always been with
Putin as far as the oligarchs concern.
You keep your nose in business,
right?
You focus on your business,
you know,
there's going to be a cut going towards
the government.
Um,
and you're good because it furthers my
agenda.
Right now you're building up these
businesses and you know,
we're making some money on the side,
but as soon as any of them start to veer
off that path and maybe get some
political aspiration,
then it's done.
And that's,
and that's when turns on them.
So,
and he's been very effective at doing
it.
Yeah,
I mean terrifyingly so it does it open
publicly.
Yeah.
And it gets,
again,
we look at it from a different
perspective.
We look at it go like,
how could people with a straight face,
you know,
stand by while he gets a fourth term and
he's just like,
you know,
president for life.
Right.
Well,
look over China.
She has spent the past few years locking
that down,
right.
Building up the security apparatus.
Um,
you know,
kind of stepping on this idea that
somehow there's a rule of law.
Uh,
he's now built back up this,
this,
this a cult of personality that we
haven't really seen since Shell Ping or
are certainly Mau and he's there for
good.
And so that gives them a strategic
advantage,
right?
Because they can look at problems in the
long haul.
Whereas here we're looking at it in an
election cycle.
So when we've got a major issue to deal
with with China,
she's not looking at it and thinking,
okay,
well yeah I got to sort this out in the
next short period of time.
He's looking at it and thinking trump's
got maybe two years left.
Right,
right.
Maybe,
maybe he gets reelected,
maybe he doesn't,
you know,
I have no idea.
But that's how he,
that's how he's processing this and it's
going to be a transitionary time in
between the two candidates or the two
presidents where things get real sloppy
and they might be able to slip in
something.
Right.
And you talk about that.
I mean the Chinese really do play the
long game,
right?
They really play the long game.
They'll,
they'll put a,
an asset here in the country to go to
school.
Right.
And they'll,
their only job is to get excellent
grades and then they'll go to grad
school and they'll get excellent grades
and then they'll go get a job somewhere.
And it doesn't really matter necessarily
where they get a job,
but they'll get a job and then they'll
get another job and eventually they are
working at a raytheon or they're working
at corning or they're working at some
company that's got some relevance,
um,
from their perspective in terms of what
they do.
And that's a 25,
30 year commitment.
Right.
And they,
and they,
they do that all the time.
And you know,
we tend to look at things in a shorter
timeframe,
right.
I mean,
even from an Intel service,
we'll,
our officers will get out there and
they'll think,
okay,
we've got to make some recruitment's,
you know,
and I got maybe two years here and on
the ground and it's that sort of
deployment or that sort of tour.
And,
uh,
it's not that 30 year commitment because
if I'm the officer,
I'm getting promoted based on how many
recruitments I get,
I'm not getting necessarily promoted
based on how well I handle assets that
have already been promoted.
And that was a critic,
the plot of the young American,
the American's show,
right?
The,
the show about Russian spies who
pretended to be just normal American
citizens moved in,
did the whole thing talk with the normal
accent.
That's right.
That came out of that New Jersey
incident with Anna Chapman.
And that was those,
those individuals were just basically
there to exist.
Right.
Their whole point of of being was just
to see whether they bump into somebody
of interest and they wouldn't going to
be responsible for them developing that
potential target.
That would be somebody else's
responsibility and that person who was
had the responsibility to develop that
target,
it wouldn't be their responsibility to
maybe task them or make some sort light
pitch that would be somebody else's
responsibility.
So there's people up that food chain
that take on more and more
responsibility if they find happened to
find the targets of interest.
That's,
and that's just the resources devoted to
one part of the country.
So it's a cautious,
well thought out,
long term plan.
Yeah.
I mean it's,
it's,
and it's,
I mean sometimes the Russians are just
as like a shotgun approach,
right.
They'll pitch everybody and see what
happens right there.
They're not quite as,
as a patient and as long term as the
Chinese are.
Um,
we've caught,
yeah.
Chinese spies doing this as well.
Oh,
sure.
Yeah.
We just bagged one,
uh,
who was working on behalf of the Chinese
government against the interests of the,
of the agency.
How long ago was this?
And it's just passed a,
I mean,
it's,
it's become public over the past weekend
in particular,
but it's been bubbling away for a while.
What's this dude's name?
Um,
I,
yeah,
I'm going to leave it at that only
because it's know,
I'm not sure if I've seen it in print,
but a Chinese American and,
um,
you know,
obviously part of the attraction for
bringing that person into the agency was
there Chinese language.
Right,
right.
Well,
part of the attraction from the Chinese
Intel perspective is the Chinese ethnic
background,
first generation,
second generation,
third generation,
doesn't matter.
They tend to play off that very well.
So anyway,
this individual worked for the agency
for a period of time,
uh,
then left and then,
set up shop overseas.
Um,
and then his actions became suspect.
and so that's,
that's when we ended up getting him.
But uh,
that,
that happens.
And when you catch somebody who's been
engaged in that first thought is,
you know,
thank God we caught them.
Um,
and the second is how,
you know,
how does someone,
how does someone do that?
How does somebody now I say that again,
not to be self righteous because we're
always out there looking for targets,
you know,
to recruit,
to turn on their country.
So,
you know,
if we could find ourselves in Iranian
scientists,
it's not like we would be coy and say,
well,
we don't want to put them in under that
stress of recruiting them.
Of course we do for national security
interests.
But I mean,
just from a psychological perspective,
you,
you think about that,
you know,
in terms of our ideas,
that we're doing that stuff for good and
that they're doing that stuff for bag,
which is very convenient that we think
that way,
but,
right,
right.
But I,
I guess,
uh,
you're,
you're absolutely right.
And,
and,
you know,
I understand they'll,
the people out there who say,
well,
that's,
you know,
you can't make that equivalent.
I don't know.
But I had never had any problem.
I never had any problem,
uh,
determining the good people from the bad
people.
You know.
And that's like today,
one of the senators in the confirmation
hearing,
and he,
I'm sorry to keep going back to the CIA,
does a director designate confirmation
hearings up on the hill.
But,
uh,
one of the senators,
it almost sound like he was trying to
make some moral equivalency between
terrorists and agency officers who were,
uh,
doing what they were,
allowed to do underneath the laws of
that time.
And the Doj Department of Justice
regulations,
uh,
and legal readings.
And,
uh,
and his point was,
well,
if you a somebody,
well then what happens if one of your
people got picked up by terrorists and
they were waterboarded would you think
that that was justified?
And I'm thinking,
okay,
wait,
it's a very odd construct.
Or if we're for a question and you know,
I think frankly if isis or al Qaeda or,
or Boko Haram picked up one of our
people and all they did would waterboard
them,
you know,
that would be a happy day,
right?
Because they don't operate under any
laws,
which is what you need.
A hospital said she handled the question
very well and kind of shut it down.
Um,
but this idea that sometimes you'll bump
into that where people,
I don't know what it is,
it the,
they're apologists
act as if we're the bad guys and anyway,
yeah,
yeah.
What am I to know?
That's exactly what it is,
right?
I was about to say,
what do I know?
Dammit.
He pulled away from it.
But that is exactly what it is.
It's like there's apologist and they're
also trying to frame a narrative instead
of trying to understand the situation
objectively,
instead of really asking someone who was
there,
asking a bunch of people who were there
getting a sense of what was the climate,
what was going on,
what actually happened.
Instead they're trying to frame it in it
like wouldn't it be justified if someone
got hold of one of our troops and did
that to them?
Would that be justified?
There's scoring Brownie points.
Yeah.
No,
I think that's true.
I think there's so little,
and it's obviously much worse right now
with the,
with the current administration,
the president trump,
it just seems like nobody,
I mean it's like World War One,
right?
Everybody's in their trenches throwing
hand grenades,
each other.
Nobody's in the middle ground.
Nobody is even trying to get up and go
into the middle crown.
And so nobody's having those
conversations like you said,
where they,
they,
they even make a lame attempt to try to
understand what the other perspective
might be.
And in particular,
it's exhausting in the sense that not
everything that this administration,
and again,
you know,
the caveat being I didn't vote for
trump,
I didn't vote for Clinton.
I,
you know,
we've got 320 million people in this
country.
You think we could've come up with two
other candidates,
but,
uh,
who did you vote for?
Uh,
you know what,
I,
this sounds really lame,
but I just sat it out.
I couldn't get myself to go vote for,
I just thought,
I mean,
I was gonna vote for Ronald Reagan,
his ashes or something,
but I figured I'd be the only person.
So,
um,
I didn't,
I didn't vote.
I couldn't,
I couldn't figure out how we got to that
point.
Um,
and yeah,
the one person who should really be
pissed off was Bernie Sanders.
I mean,
the only collusion we've really proven
up to this point,
it's a DNC colluding to keep Bernie
down.
Yeah.
And people sweep that under the rug so
quick.
It's so adorable.
It's adorable how people just make it
like,
that's not a big deal.
The deleting of 30,000 emails,
not a big deal.
The collusion with the DNC to rig the
primary's not a big deal.
Yeah.
And Bernie,
God bless him,
he played the good soldier and you know,
fell on the sword and hasn't really,
well,
he hasn't made much of an issue of it.
I think it's,
he has aspirations
to move forward and the knows they owe
him one now and he knows that Hillary
Clinton is essentially done.
That's interesting.
If they try to bring her back in 2020
people go fucking crazy.
Like,
Hey,
you really got it.
You imagine she might have actually be
thinking that.
Well,
I'm sure she was.
Yeah,
they've probably got an or on a vitamin
IV drip right now and given her hormone
replacement therapy and I started to do
yoga.
I don't think she'll,
I don't,
I just don't see her being resurrected.
But maybe we'll try.
Maybe.
So I tell you,
I do think Joe Biden is coming in.
You think so?
Yeah.
I think he's viewing this.
I think he's very upset with himself.
Not upset with others,
but I think he,
he probably thinks at this stage of the
game and times were different.
It was tough.
We didn't regarding his family,
but I think he probably regrets not
going in the last time.
And I think we're going to see him throw
his hat in the ring because he's going
to look around and he's going to think,
what am I up against?
I'm up against a Harris and booker and
you know who else?
But I mean,
I think he's got some baggage though.
People forget about when I was in
Boston,
we used to have Joe Biden tonight at
stitches comedy club where we would
plagiarize each other's jokes because
Joe Biden,
people don't remember this,
but in the 1980s he got busted
plagiarizing Kennedy's speeches.
People forgot about that.
He ran for president in [inaudible] 88.
Yeah.
And that's a good point.
But you know,
everybody loves the guy that's sitting
on the bench,
right?
So there were a lot of Democrats,
I think after the fact that we think,
oh my God,
if joe had just run,
but he's run a couple of times,
it hasn't worked out.
And so I'll put the chewed him up.
Yeah,
I mean,
it's real.
Um,
so I,
you know,
anyway,
but what I,
it's,
it's the politics of it all or are
fascinating,
but it's just the crazy shit.
When trump was saying they'd beat him
up,
he's like crazy Joe Biden so that he
could beat me,
beat me up,
that he would go down fast and hard.
That's what it said.
I think they should've just gone with
that.
I think they should have done some sort
of celebrity match.
That's what I was done.
I was saying that like,
let me,
let me be the commentator.
Can you see what that,
I mean,
that'd be the president of,
he definitely peaked this man.
Both of them would die.
Yeah.
Oh No,
no.
They get in the cage and it'd be all
over.
I'm thinking five minutes at the hair
pull,
amy pull whatever little hair they have
left,
the old school,
the old school wrestling trunks,
boots that,
oh,
we got to get this going.
And he was just so ridiculous to see
trump tweeting that he would beat up Joe
Biden if they ever fought.
Yeah.
Who the fuck have you ever fought ever?
If you ever even thrown a punch,
this is the world we live in.
I mean,
if,
I mean you think about it,
all the,
you think,
you think about the things we should be
talking about on a daily basis.
Right.
And yet,
because of the self inflicted wounds
that they constantly have coming out of
that White House because of his
tweeting,
for the most part,
people aren't focusing on,
you know,
it's like,
look,
we should all be able to agree.
Democrats and Republicans should be able
to agree that,
yeah,
if you can get your way to peace on the
Korean Peninsula,
that's pretty good.
Yes.
Um,
no,
they just released the three North
Korean prisoners.
Well,
American citizen prisoners who were held
in North Korea.
So Secretary Pompei,
I was flying back right now from
Pyongyang and he's bringing those three
back.
That's a good thing.
That's a very good thing.
But we can't,
the way they got there,
that freaks people out.
I am saying,
is nuclear buttons bigger than the other
guys?
And it's like,
but I gotta tell you,
I was really happy watching the video of
Kim Jong.
Ooh.
And shaking hands with the president of
South Korea and the meeting and the DMZ.
I was happy that,
that to me was like,
wow,
like that made me think this might,
they're both smiling.
I know Kim Jon wounds a fucking murderer
and he killed his own uncle,
nephews and all these different people
that he thought might go against him.
But seeing him shake hands with the
president of South Korea made me think
like,
wow,
they might
settle this.
They,
they,
they could,
I mean,
look as a fairy first time,
uh,
his Grandad,
give me a song and then his dad,
Kim Jong Il,
um,
neither of them ever step foot on the
southern side of that.
DMC on the south side of peace village
never happened.
So that in itself,
you're absolutely right,
was that,
that's a major development.
Now maybe nothing comes of it,
right?
It's a low percentage shot yet to agree
there's so many moving parts.
So maybe nothing comes of it.
And then I think the administration is
making that case saying,
look,
we have to be realistic,
but you know,
this is a good thing that it's moving in
that direction.
Right.
And in fact,
this guy,
a young guy who actually likes Dennis
Rodman,
I mean Jesus Christ in his playing days.
Yeah.
I like Dennis Rodman a lot.
Right.
I just didn't it to somebody now.
Yeah.
I didn't get to,
he would develop into the character that
he is now,
but he also seems to be like some sort
of a spokesman.
If you're America talking to Korea,
it's weird.
Do you remember Robin as a player?
Man was fantastic.
A hustler.
Ah,
defense.
He was out of rebounding.
That guy could,
man,
that guy could rebound.
And if you talk to people that know him
that we're,
we're partying with him.
That guy would be up all night drinking
and partying and then show up and play
fucking phenomenal.
The next day on zero sleep comes another
title.
Oh,
good.
Yeah.
Billy Corgan was friends with Rodman and
billy Corgan from the smashing pumpkins
on the podcast was talking about how
they were mad at him because Rodman was
taking billy corgan partying and then
showing up the next day with zero sleep
and playing,
and they were blaming billy corgan.
He's like,
motherfucker,
I went to sleep.
He's like,
that guy was still out up.
That's fantastic.
Pumpkin's and coming out to boise.
Oh everybody.
Pigs coming out.
The boys.
I liked boys.
Listen,
men,
the way you talk about it or thinking
about getting a fucking house out there,
Wall Street Journal just had some of my
friends said,
you've got to stop talking about Boise.
But the of the Wall Street Journal just
had articles if fastest growing state in
the nation.
Find a hopes.
Well,
still.
Yeah.
Well,
we get so many people coming in.
We're bringing the wolves,
the sort of,
sort
that out.
It's a balancing thing.
Yeah.
Don't hike too far.
Fuck yeah.
Well,
you could go,
you go 10 minutes outside of,
of,
uh,
amy,
we're right downtown basically.
But you go right at 10 minutes time
church wilderness,
right up in the foothills and you don't
see anybody in the next name.
It's fantastic.
Fishing is great.
We got more river mileage than any other
state except for Alaska.
Yeah,
the fishing supposed to be incredible.
Fly Fishing for trout and if you like
fly fishing,
if you like,
if you like trout,
this is,
it's a place to be.
I mean other states,
Montana,
some other spots will say no,
I tell us.
But them two is what it really,
it shouldn't be.
Whose number one?
It's like they're both fucking awesome.
I mean we,
we,
to be fair,
we got the best trout but still better
than Montana.
I think.
So.
Well of a trout off.
Well,
I have friends up there in,
what is that fucking we're firstlight
is,
where the hell are they?
They're in some small town,
some ski resort area.
Real high end ski place up in Montana.
No,
no,
no.
Oh uh,
oh.
Catch him.
The cat town is catch them.
The resort at Sun Valley.
They rave about it.
They say it's fucking incredible.
Yeah.
We were just up there.
We've got a place up in another ski area
and it sits on a lake and like Sun
Valley Ketchum doesn't have a big
summertime.
They'll traction attraction like the
massive lake.
But our place sits on a pay at lake and
it's got a great little ski place
nearby.
But there are a lot of areas like that.
But catch him,
catch him is a great town,
great little community.
Um,
the skiing at Sun Valley's is,
is really good.
It's not like Aspen or,
or good,
it's not exactly,
exactly,
but it's park city where there places
those are just filled with rich people
too.
It's like,
it's,
they're overrun with like high end
stores.
And look,
I love Sun Valley.
I think it's gorgeous.
I mean,
I'm not Sun Valley,
um,
uh,
Deer Valley,
Utah.
It's fucking gorgeous up there.
But man,
it's just all like wealthy skiing
places.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
It,
yeah.
When I want to spend,
you know,
$2,000 for a pair of ski boots,
that's where I go.
But if you want like a normal burger and
a beer,
you know,
catch him or mccall up there in Idaho,
it's,
it's really good.
You're gonna,
you're gonna,
you're gonna love,
you're gonna get a great reception up.
I can't wait.
Boyz II men.
I purposely decided to go there just to
check it out.
I decided to book a Gig up there.
Just take a couple of days and,
and you know,
spend a little time up there,
maybe do some fish and we'll,
we'll go fishing.
I'll take you out fishing.
Well,
I have a friend up there that I actually
just know from Internet,
but he,
uh,
he got into knows,
well,
I know people who actually know him in
real life,
but I've,
I've only talked to him online,
but he's got a pet coyote.
He actually took a kylie as a cub and
we've talked about him on the podcast
many times.
I'm going to meet his pet coyote and he
recently got a pet badger.
He found a fucking baby badger this
dude.
Yeah,
man.
That's what you want.
Yeah.
Honey Badger.
They don't,
well,
little apparently you could raise a bat.
His,
his,
uh,
instagram is Seth Simpson.
And when we tell you what it is,
because it will pull up the video,
Jamie,
because it's pretty fucking hilarious.
Ryan Callahan,
my friend just tweeted me or just texted
me.
He's my friend and catch him guys.
Uh,
but this dude,
um,
has,
uh,
so he's got a coyote and a bad,
yeah,
Seth Simpson.
Two Oh eight.
Somebody sent me a clip.
It is fucking,
so they're shooting squirrels.
And then look,
he's got his little,
this is a new pet coyote that he has and
this is a new one.
And this little coyote puppy is chewing
on this squirrel.
But,
or I'm sorry,
not squirrel.
They're shooting pigeons.
That squirrels.
But he's a go down and see the badgers.
See The badger up there in the right
hand side corner.
Look at this.
This is a badger baby.
So it says,
um,
someone was shooting ground squirrels is
shore Badgett caring what they thought
was a squirrel.
They shot it and it was actually
carrying a baby.
So they took this baby badger and now
they're raising it and he's raising this
baby badger and he says that you can,
uh,
given the option of fight or flight,
they're often fight,
but if their bottle fed,
handled constantly and extremely well
socialized,
they can be kept in captivity for four
easily or easily and make fun pets.
How crazy is that guy's got a pet
badger.
God,
don't Piss that thing off.
No.
Uh,
this,
this guy has had nothing to do with a
badger,
although it's a boost to talking about
small animals.
Uh,
somebody sent me a clip of,
of,
uh,
an incident where a police officer's
driving down the road.
Then he stopped traffic on both sides
cause a groundhog was trying to come
across the street.
Right?
And so he was trying to,
it was about a quarter of the way across
this two lane road and he was trying to
back it off the street.
Okay.
That was a nice humanitarian thing,
right?
He's trying to help this animal get off
or it doesn't get hit by cars.
And this,
uh,
he keeps trying and keeps trying.
It's not working.
You know,
the groundhog won't leave and eventually
the groundhog,
I guess something snapped in his mind.
Then he decided,
you know,
fuck this,
I'm going to go after this police
officer.
Right.
I guess he got tired.
So he,
he kind of waddled up to the police
officer.
But it,
this is it.
Yeah.
This is it.
Now watch what happens.
This is insane.
So the COP has 10.
Oh,
he didn't shoot it.
He did.
He got on his knees and shot the fucking
groundhog.
I like how they blur it out.
Yeah.
The identity.
The identity of the groundhog.
Yeah.
So it's moving away now.
It's still moving.
Does he show it again?
Yes.
But watch it comes at form again.
Well
that seems inappropriate.
I grabbed the police said was blocking
traffic was fatally shot Sunday.
I knew I was in the New York daily.
There was this Maryland.
Oh boy.
Uh,
he realized that it was not responding
as an,
as expected for an animal that was not
being cornered or trapped believing the
groundhog to be either sick,
injured.
He shot it.
And I love it.
I love this response.
I am sure the officer did the best thing
in this situation.
It's not for me to judge.
Yeah.
If you can't kick a groundhogs ass,
you shouldn't be a cop.
That's what I have to say that because I
don't know.
It's coming after you sidestep pitch and
also you can't take it down with one
shot.
What the Hell is wrong with that?
Wow.
How slow is it moving too?
It was just,
it was,
it was like,
you know,
they're not the fastest animals,
so,
uh,
it was not in a full sprint towards this
officer.
I'd just say,
who knows?
None of us can put ourselves in that
officer's shoes.
Let's just put it that way.
These getting an irrational fear of
mammals.
None of us have been in combat against a
small animal creature,
would it?
I mean I fucking groundhog.
I know.
What do you got it too?
It seems like you just get out of the
way.
You have to shoot a groundhog.
Yeah.
Just get back in your cruiser and assume
people are going to drive around it.
Yeah.
Anyway.
I thought that was interesting and
someone thought it was interesting
enough to send along,
so that was crazy.
I did that.
I think sometimes you give people a gun
that just looking to shoot some after a
while I'm shooting something.
Oh,
this groundhog is fucking with society.
It's like,
it's like that old far side cartoon with
the vultures sitting up there and
saying,
damn it,
I'm just going to kill something.
Right.
So you know that expression,
if you only have a hammer,
everything seems like a male.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I mean if you gave that Cabo can of bear
spray,
well that's a good point.
Less than deadly force.
Right?
It could have tased it.
Uh,
probably,
Eh,
probably would've killed it.
Killed it.
Right.
Would it made for a more interesting
video?
Just give him a tennis racket.
Slapping in the ass.
I could get a move on a little fella.
Just pull the tennis racket off your
utility belt.
It stopped traffic.
That sounds like a dumb ground squirrel
too.
He's about to get fucked up by a dumb
ground.
Squirrel.
It was suicide by cop.
Maybe it was one of those deals you
think it was just you got an issue on
squirrel.
I had enough,
like crazy person that rushes the cop
because he wants to die.
We get that night.
Oh,
you get that deer that just like,
I just want to end it all they do.
They just come out of nowhere and you
know they've been sitting in the bushes
waiting for you to drive by so they get
super confused during September,
October,
November during the Rut in particular,
like when they get horny,
there's a video,
a hilarious video.
This deer that's so fucked up from the
Rut that this guy walks up to it and
taps it on the head with an Arrow on the
like,
I've seen that joan,
I deer hunter in the country was like,
well fuck,
this is what I was hunting because most
of the time of deer even catches wind
that you're a 200 yards away.
They fucking bound out of there like the
hills are on fire.
How did you do out in Hawaii?
I've got two.
I've got two axis deer that looked
great.
Yeah.
This deer is just a macy aided for
running paralyzed and confused with his
own hormones and this guy walks up to it
and just taps it.
This is crazy.
Like this thing is just so baffled.
Hey Buddy.
I mean,
that is crazy.
The deer.
Hi.
It looks like he's definitely done.
Yeah.
When they get run it up.
Like when they're like,
I've never seen anything like this
before,
but sometimes they just blow a fuse.
This,
he's tapping the antlers.
Hey Fella.
It's just too much to to process for
that deer.
Yeah.
Look at it.
Yes,
I could leave,
but I don't know what to do,
but it doesn't seem like it understands
life anymore.
Like we thought it'd be just stands
really still.
He won't be spotted now is that,
and now he takes off.
What in the fuck man.
That's just,
that's his hormones.
That's men.
That's great.
That's what happens when you do is get
boners guys get their kidney stolen from
Russian.
You know those gals that take your
kidney,
you wake up in a bathtub full of ice and
your wallet's rid of that before.
Oh yeah.
Oregon missing.
Yeah.
It used to happen out in Southeast Asia.
There were occasionally reports of that.
Yeah.
I that was out there for quite a while
and occasionally you'd hear a yeah,
some reports,
some dude getting screwed up and,
and uh,
you know,
next thing you know,
he wakes up and he's missing a kidney or
yeah.
Think it really did happen or did
happen.
You think about what that means.
So not only does it do get knocked out,
but then you got to get the doctor in.
Right.
Cause they're not,
you know,
the girls probably aren't doing it
themselves with rubber gloves on weight.
Right.
Just say,
yeah.
It sounds like a bad movie.
What?
It could be a good movie actually.
Not very good.
Yeah.
So it does,
it does,
it does happen.
And,
and uh,
all the more reason to always know where
your pants are.
That's a good move.
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't know.
You should definitely know.
Your parents are,
your parents are,
I know what you're drinking kids just,
I'm just telling you kids,
I used to tell my dog my daughter's
phone off.
You know how I keep bashing China and
their intellectual property
acquisitions.
Uh,
my daughter's now in China.
Well,
no,
working in Beijing.
She working for the government?
No,
no,
no.
She's,
she's worshiping.
Thank you.
Uh,
and uh,
she's a great kid,
but she always says,
you know,
dad,
could you just,
uh,
could you just not maybe bash them as
often as you do if I'm flying back over
there to,
you don't have to work.
They asked her questions.
Oh No,
no,
I don't think that Swat,
I don't think they give a crap,
although I will say I was giving a
speech one time about,
uh,
about national security issues and I got
off on the subject of the intellectual
property theft that's perpetrated by a
lot of different countries and it was a
large conference.
And uh,
so I'm talking about the Chinese and
their tendency to do this.
And I looked down in there,
I see a guy that I know who's with one
of the companies that brought me in for
this speech and he's got this funny look
on his face.
Like,
oh my God,
I can't believe you're talking about
this.
And he kind of like motions over there
and they're in like the third row of
this,
this area is this contingent of Chinese
business folks sitting there and they
just look,
and I've just been spending 10 minutes
just,
just railing and talking about,
you know,
how awful they can be sometimes in this
whole,
although good,
I praise them because they're good at
it.
Uh,
and they,
they looked to it,
they were just horrified about this
whole thing.
What am I gonna do?
I can't walk that back,
you know.
Anyway,
look,
it is what it is.
If you don't want me to talk about it,
don't do it.
Don't do it.
Yeah.
Um,
so that's,
uh,
that's another issue.
I'm just ticking off all the issues that
we've solved here so far.
We get that we're going to face the
world here,
Mike Baker,
but that the North Korean released to
those prisoners.
That's a good thing.
This is a good thing.
And I think both trump and pence,
I think of going out to Andrews Air
Force base to meet them as they come in.
And,
you know,
but it will be,
it'll be interesting to see,
look,
it was,
I think it was an easy give for Kim Jong
Un to do.
Right.
And what were they over there in prison
for?
Well,
one of them what I'm wants a businessman
and he was serving 10 years hard labor.
Imagine hard labor camp and with Korea,
uh,
for supposedly for espionage.
He's a business guy and they don't care.
I mean,
they've done this numerous times in the
past.
It really doesn't matter if you show up
and you're in business.
The other two were also interesting.
They were academics.
They were at the Pyongyang University
for Science and technology.
Both of them were teaching there,
which is oddly enough where I got my
degree.
Um,
and um,
uh,
my undergrad degree,
Pyongyang University,
uh,
I went there for the sports.
Uh,
and uh,
and I worked during the year as the mat.
It's the peel and gang missiles.
Um,
like a guy dressed as a missile.
You know,
I just,
I can't,
you know,
honest to God,
I can't remember where I was going with
the story.
And so I just like rambling until I get
my head straight.
I'm like that deer in that video.
So those two were,
were again the same thing,
supposedly engaged in espionage and so
they got chucked in.
Um,
so we'll see.
I mean,
I,
you know,
whether,
whether we're able to get anything from
this,
who knows,
but that's a good sign.
The fact that he met with,
as you pointed out,
President Moon from South Korea.
Very good sign.
Um,
the Chinese have a,
they sent their foreign minister over to
Pyongyang,
um,
couple of weeks ago.
First time foreign minister has been
over there and maybe 11 years,
12 years.
Wow.
So they understand the importance of
this and I think everybody's,
the dynamic has shifted because I think,
you know,
we've kicked the can down the road for
so long that there were basically at the
point where their programs are close to
being fully developed.
And I think the,
you know,
the Chinese understand that that means
that all those other options perhaps of
kicking the can down the road aren't on
the decision tree anymore.
And so,
you know,
they don't want chaos on the peninsula.
They don't want military conflict.
Nobody does.
And so I think the Chinese for basically
the first time I've been aggressively
assisting with the sanctions that were
put in place that had a very quick
response on Kim Jong Un,
he's not suicidal,
he just wants to survive in position of
leadership.
Right?
So he's looking at it thinking,
okay,
the calculus has changed so I gotta do
something different.
And again,
you know,
being pragmatic,
maybe it doesn't work,
but at least we're trying.
And I think that's a good thing.
So
no,
unquestionably,
it's a good thing.
And also the video that North Korean
soldier fleeing and getting shot shot at
as he escapes North Korea,
I mean that had to get to North Korea
to,
and they realize like Jesus Christ is
the second guy and how many months that
was fleeing like that and got away and
they're finding parasites in their body.
And extreme malnourishment.
And this is a soldier.
So you gotta think everybody over there
is probably in an in dire straits.
Right?
And we've talked about this in terms of
just,
just a simple,
not simple,
but the idea that,
you know,
the population in terms of its physical
stature compared to the South Korea,
they're shorter.
They're,
they're uh,
uh,
a malnutrition issue.
Yeah.
I think also I think they've realized
that there's only so much they can do
going forward to lock the place down.
Right.
And technology at some point,
even though it's North Korea and there's
not a lot there,
there's enough.
And I think there's a sense that they,
you know,
how long can they can control the
population the way they have.
So again,
he's not the Kim,
uh,
is not suicidal.
He wants to maintain power.
When you think about every country
action,
its own best interest for every leader
acts in their own best interest.
That's his thought process.
And how do I do that?
Well,
okay.
You know,
maybe,
so I think that it could happen.
We could get something really good out
of this.
We'll see.
You know,
but the Iranians who are watching it and
North Koreans are watching what we did
over the Iran.
I disagree with that.
That whole notion that North Koreans are
going to look at it and go,
Eh,
it means we can't trust them.
Look,
if President Obama was so enamored with
that,
that deal that he made with the Iranians
will then take it to the Senate,
right.
Get it,
make it a treaty.
You made it a,
an agreement,
an executive order basically.
And so,
you know,
they're not looking,
I don't think the North Koreans were
looking at this and going,
trump is going back on his word.
I think they're looking at and going,
trump's okay.
He means that he's not gonna put up with
a,
a bad deal and this wasn't that good a
deal.
So I think that's the way that they
would process it.
And,
and we'll see.
But you know,
who knows where they were on,
he was going to go with what they're
doing.
And,
uh,
people right now listening are probably
thinking,
okay,
I'm tired of listening about the
Iranians.
I mean,
well that seems to be something that you
were really concerned about.
Well,
I think only because,
um,
you know,
if,
if it's,
if it's not handled properly and there's
a lot of moving parts,
meaning our allies,
uh,
meaning the wildcard of what Rouhani and
the regime was going to do.
But look,
make no mistake,
there's no this,
no,
this idea that somehow that this was a
moderate Iranian regime,
all you gotta do is look at what they're
engaged in doing in the Lebanon and
Yemen and the proxy war with,
with the Saudis and others,
uh,
in Iraq and Syria,
in,
in the work that they're doing it in all
the soldiers,
US soldiers,
they killed in Iraq,
you know,
through the provision of weapons,
the training that they gave to,
uh,
to,
the Iraqis that were fighting against
us.
Yeah.
Look at all of that.
And you think,
you know,
at what point did somebody make some
decision that the Iranians were,
you know,
somehow moderate because they're there.
They're not,
that regime isn't,
you know,
the people themselves.
I think we keep hoping one day.
I mean you go all the way back to the
fall of the Shah and you know,
people hoping that the people will rise
up and overthrow the clerics.
Do you think
same attitude that causes people to be
apologists,
like the same attitude it's causing
people to ask.
How do you feel about those people being
tortured?
Is it the same sort of mentality that
allows people to want those Iranians to
be a,
the want the people that are empowered
to be moderate?
Yeah,
I think so.
I think it's a,
it's,
I think there's an element of that.
I think it's,
it's,
um,
it's a desire to,
again,
sort of think,
well I'd add that part of it I don't
really understand.
Again,
cause you would think that you would
base that on people's performance and
all you gotta do is look at past
performance of the clerics and the
regime there in Iran that runs things.
And I don't know how you come away from
it thinking,
well,
you know,
they're being actually pretty,
pretty moderate.
They're being pretty conciliatory.
I,
you know,
and that's what we got to previous
administration did.
They just stretched themselves then
trying to sell this deal.
I mean,
they did everything they could to try to
race to it,
make sure it was going to happen.
They set things aside.
Uh,
and you know,
we've caught the Iranians in the past
cheating and that,
this,
this business with Netanyahu,
when he came out with this information
that they pulled out of this warehouse
where it's being stored.
Yes.
That was,
you know,
historical covered the period of 1999 to
2003.
What was that again?
Well,
the Word Messiah,
uh,
had an operation that they engaged in.
Um,
there was a warehouse in tech,
Ron,
where,
um,
the Iranian regime,
rather than destroy all their research
and all the work that we're doing on
nuclear weapons,
uh,
up until that time,
you know,
uh,
during that time they stored it.
And so they put it in a warehouse
facility.
Um,
massage.
and some others liaison service found
out that,
uh,
that the location and then they mounted
an operation,
which is a very labor intensive to try
to,
you got to do a lot of surveillance.
You gotta recruit assets.
Who can provide you with key information
about this.
And then eventually they hiked out a
bunch of these documents.
They don't,
you know,
50,000 pages of documents and almost 200
cds,
uh,
or,
um,
and that information covers 1999 to
2003.
And one of the things that it shows
definitively is that one of the things
that you're running is,
were doing were they were designing and
looking to build a minimum of five
nuclear warheads,
right.
For their ballistic missiles that they
are also developing a building,
which puts a nail in that whole idea
that it was nothing but a peaceful
program.
Um,
but people looking at it,
they're apologists and the sink,
oh,
it's,
it's old history.
It's old news.
It doesn't tell us anything new.
Well,
it tells us and confirms to us what
we've been saying all along,
which is,
you know,
they were lying about it and they were
lying about the,
the extent of their centrifuge
operations,
um,
the extent of the stored materials that
they had.
And so I,
you know,
I'm not,
I just don't know how you make that leap
to then say,
okay,
now they're fine.
You know,
now that now we can believe them.
Why?
Because why I don't get,
I don't get that part.
So I'm not willing to see it until they
want to give us 100% access to all their
sites.
They want to say,
come on in and look at Parchin come on
and look at the military facilities that
we used to be where we are used for
weapons development in the past.
Great.
Now you got something and now I'll back
off and say,
okay,
you know,
maybe that's a good deal.
Actually give us access to all those
sites.
Um,
and let us go in and look around the
IAEA,
which is the international organization
for inspection of,
of,
of these nuclear sites.
They spent 12 years trying to figure out
what the hell was going on at Parchin,
which is a military site near terror and
never,
never were able to get the access they
needed,
never were able to solve the,
you know,
the,
the question.
And they went on and on with the
investigation.
Well,
guess what,
as a result of the drive by the
administration to get a deal signed,
part of the,
the conditions from the Iranian regime
was that they stopped this
investigation,
just draw a line under it.
They had no,
they had no answers,
but they just said,
well,
no,
we're not gonna sign a deal unless you
stop that investigation.
So,
so we did,
we stopped the investigation.
And then,
like I said,
they also say,
well,
you can visit our sites,
our military.
Ah,
okay,
fine.
We won't,
uh,
you know,
by the way,
we,
you know,
this doesn't affect our business.
A ballistic missile technology
developments are a weapons program.
Ah,
okay,
fine.
Who's doing made this decisions?
Well,
this was,
uh,
two years is as his former secretary
Kerry would like to say,
well,
you know,
it was two years of diplomatic work and
hard negotiation,
hard negotiation.
It's,
come on,
you know,
so,
uh,
you know,
we worked reportedly in concert with the
Brits and the French and the Germans and
the Russians and the Chinese.
Uh,
although it was mostly,
you know,
from our side,
um,
and yeah,
know it is what it is.
So are they complying with what they've
got in,
in the terms of the agreement?
Yeah,
fine.
But I like,
like I said,
I just think,
and it kind of goes to that point about
there's,
the truth is always kind of in the
middle,
right?
I mean,
the truth is somewhere there,
it's not like it's not,
it's not me throwing grenades at the,
at the progressive is little laughter.
The Democrats saying,
Eh,
you know,
it's a terrible deal at socks.
And Alex,
I said,
no,
look,
I deal could be good.
And I'm glad that we've been able to
inspect those sites that have been
available.
That's a good thing.
But don't couch it as something that's
not,
and you know,
if the Brits and the French and the
Germans are now willing to say it's an
inadequate deal,
but we still want to stay in,
um,
you know,
that should,
that should tell people something and,
and,
you know,
but anyway,
that's not where we're at.
We're at,
everybody stands around screaming at the
sky because they're upset about one side
or the other.
And you know,
crap doesn't get done.
How much time do you spend thinking
about this?
Cause you're,
you're,
you're in civilian life now.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
are you,
are you ever really in civilian life?
Oh,
you were in civilian?
Yeah.
No,
we are.
Of course we are.
Yeah.
Um,
and uh,
and thank God for that.
Uh,
because it's a young person's game.
Um,
but,
uh,
I spend,
I probably spend more time,
I don't have a lot of friends,
so I invite you to go fishing.
Come on Joe,
be my friend.
Go fishing with me,
I'll go fishing with him.
We'll just sit around and say it like it
was good fishing,
but he only wanted to do was talk about
it.
Ron fucking boring.
So,
um,
yeah,
I,
you know,
I'd probably spend a little more time,
but I will tell you what's fun is it,
is it,
some of it does rub off,
right?
Like my three little guys,
you know,
or even my daughter,
she loves international fair.
She loves international relations.
And what's going on in the world.
She travels a lot and I think that's
good.
Right?
So maybe some of that rubbed off,
you know,
sitting around the dinner table and
talking about these things or me banging
on about it and I thought every now and
then I think I'm being boring.
But maybe they picked up on something
and sometimes my kids will,
will say something,
you know,
and they'll like,
like scooter the oldest one,
he's wanting me it shit.
He's only 10 years old.
Um,
the governor came in or a governor
candidate can make,
cause we're coming up on an election
cycle.
A governor candidate came in and go,
guy,
we don't,
you know,
nice guy.
And he came in and to talk to Her ben's
class,
right?
Fifth Grade Class.
And you know,
ben raised his hand during the question
period and said,
so what would you do differently?
Because Idaho was ranked 43rd in
education.
And I know he said this because this
guy,
they called me later and he says,
your kid has his question.
First of all,
I was going to say,
hey,
come on.
You know,
we want more homework.
Lighten up.
Yeah.
Give us more homework.
But you know,
the point being is,
is you know,
my wife,
uh,
the world's greatest person,
um,
is in politics and focused and you know,
strategy and campaign problems and all
sorts of things.
So she talks about it as well.
So maybe the kids absorb something like
that.
And maybe if you talk about these things
at home,
oh,
this is not rocket science,
right?
But maybe you talk about these things at
home.
Maybe the kids do pick up on some of it.
Are they,
they start to imagine that there's
something else other than just,
you know,
what happens on the school yard,
you know?
I Dunno.
I know.
So I guess there's an upside to it.
I don't know where I'm going with that
to look on like,
oh my God,
this is certainly an upside to talking
about things.
And the more kids know now,
the better it is.
But we don't teach civics.
Right?
I mean,
we don't teach civics in school that the
workings of government,
how the government is supposed to work.
Yeah.
Most people get out of high school and
they barely understand what's the
difference between the Congress and the
Senate.
Right.
And so then,
then you get what we get,
which is people reading crap on twitter
and thinking that it's always true or
that's how they formed their opinion.
Or it's all this,
or it's all of that.
The world is not that the world exists
somewhere in the,
in the middle ground.
But we don't,
we don't,
I don't think we,
you know,
we're,
we're failing our kids,
um,
by a desire to make life easier for
them.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I think there's definitely some truth to
that.
Um,
I mean,
I think
there's a shocking lack of adversary or
adversity rather,
that a lot of people have to go through
in this life.
And,
um,
when you,
you go through too much soft living,
you start to develop these lazy habits
and this distorted perception of reality
and a lack of understanding of what,
what really hard work is and how
difficult it is to get by in this life
if you don't live in this cushy place
that we live in.
Yeah.
Did you work when you were a kid?
Did you work summer jobs?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
A lot of construction jobs mostly.
Yeah.
I mean the same thing when we,
we,
you know,
I blacktop parking lots.
There's a fix it job.
Right.
That's,
it's a good,
it's,
but you know what?
You made some money yet.
You felt good about it.
At the end of the day you were
exhausted.
But,
um,
I,
you know,
I tell my kids,
I mean,
they get you,
they to have to start,
you know,
the,
the oldest one's going to be 11 soon.
It's time for him to do something and
get a paper route,
you know,
mow lawns.
So he's talking make a mow lawns at 11.
Sure.
Yeah.
You could have mowed lawns this year.
Um,
but uh,
uh,
yeah.
I mean it seems early that early to push
a lawn mower.
That's not,
I didn't have a lawnmower job when I was
11.
That seems early.
No,
I don't think so.
I think it's,
you know,
you tell them where not to put their
feet in their hands and their gut.
Let the little fella have a life,
get them involved in sports.
They don't play,
they'll play a lot of lacrosse.
They play a lot of basketball.
They shovel snow yet.
Swim team.
Yeah.
They shovel snow.
They get out there and the 10 year old,
the eight year olds a shovel snow during
the winter,
a six year olds like,
yeah,
mugs,
he's not doing a lot.
Got figure out a way out of this shit.
He's going to be management.
I think that's what he's gonna do.
He's going to be management somehow.
Uh,
but uh,
yeah,
the,
the work ethic.
I think you're absolutely right.
I mean we every,
okay,
every generation,
right?
Like my parents wanted it to be easier
for me and my brothers,
right.
And their parents I'm sure want it to be
easier for them.
Right.
And nobody,
and so you do that,
but eventually you get to diminishing
returns because it becomes so easy and
you know,
the kids forget what it is.
Like to actually have to work for
something and to compete and to compete
and yeah,
we can't all,
it's,
it's like that I saw some story,
not that I troll them,
the social media,
but there was a story that popped up
that some community,
uh,
they had a cheer squad try out and one
of the girls didn't make it on cheer
squad.
I didn't even know what cheer squad,
I guess the cheerleaders and the mom was
upset and so she went and complained.
And so the school decision was that
everybody who tried out gets to be on
this squad.
Yeah.
You can imagine what that looks like.
You got to teach kids the opposite,
that if you didn't do good enough,
you need to figure out what you did
wrong and go back and improve and work
on it.
And then if you do get in next year,
you'll get an amazing feeling of
accomplishment rather than an amazing
feeling of entitlement.
Right.
You,
you belong in everything you try out
for.
Well,
that's going to be a big fat wake up
call when you go out to compete
the workforce.
Right.
Nobody's going to chow.
My God.
Nobody.
Nobody's going to cut you any slack.
Theoretical fully.
Yeah,
but no,
that's,
that's right.
The idea that,
you know,
you got to you,
I mean it's like my,
my two older boys or if people are
thinking,
oh gosh,
Mike's now talking about his kids all
the time.
Uh,
my two little boys,
I have gotten to the point now where the
sports thing they play and if they don't
play well,
they sit right.
Because earlier than that,
you know,
everybody plays right.
It's equal playing time.
You know,
that's what you typically get the
coaches here and that's a good thing.
They little kids are learning how to
play the game of where to stand and all
the rest of it.
So,
but then they get to a certain point,
it becomes merit based or it should
anyway,
which is how it works in Idaho
basically.
At least with the teams that were we
were associated with.
Instead,
if you're,
if you don't play that well then maybe
you don't make the team.
And if you make the team and you're not
playing as well as the other kids and
you're sitting on the bench.
And so you know,
my kids,
you know,
when it first started happening,
they were just,
they were complaining,
you know,
like,
screw it,
I'm not getting any playing time.
And I'm thinking,
well,
okay,
what's the next part of that thought
process that you need to work your way
through?
If you're not getting enough playing
time,
it's because you're not what planning as
well as you should be compared to the
other kids.
Therefore,
what do you need to do?
So you have to walk them through this
process.
And that's okay because kids don't know
this stuff inherently.
Maybe.
And so you teach them that,
but you don't teach them that while
you're,
you're right.
Why don't you try a different sport or
you know,
or you're right,
we should talk to the coach about your
characters.
You too difficult for the children and
they're not having a good time.
And it should be about companionship and
it shouldn't be about competition.
Well,
you're setting your kid up for failure
because it can be about both.
It could be about companionship,
but also about competition and,
right.
Look,
the world's competition,
it's filled with it.
If you're not competing,
if you're,
if you just decide you don't want to
have anything to do with competition,
that's your choice.
But if you engage in something that does
require competition,
you want special access.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
If you,
if you don't,
if you're not that nature,
if you don't have that competitive side
of you and okay,
fine,
but then don't go through the rest of
life thinking,
we'll just,
because life is a competition,
which you know,
may upset you when you find that out,
that you don't get special dispensation
just because you're not a competitive
person.
It does it.
Yeah.
So I agree with it.
Participation Trophies,
all the nonsense that's going on today.
Well,
I was,
uh,
I was walking,
one of my boys,
they all just went off the,
off the lacrosse field not too long ago.
And he said,
how'd I do?
And I said,
well,
you could've done better.
You could have played harder.
He just wasn't into it.
Right.
It was tired or whatever.
So he kind of looked at me and I didn't
realize I was walking and there were
some parents around me and as we were
walking across the field,
and so he kind of looks at me and I knew
what he was thinking,
which is Dan,
that's not right.
And so I looked at her,
I said,
do you want me to be honest with you and
you want me to just stand here and blow
smoke up your ass?
And I found out did a couple of parents
who were upset about the fact that I
would say that,
but he knew exactly what I meant.
And he said,
no,
you should be honest.
And I said,
well,
this,
the parents were upset at you for being
honest.
Yeah,
yeah,
exactly.
And,
and you know,
to be fair,
muggsy the youngest one got called in
for,
uh,
I've done,
it's just,
he got called a fuse in the word Douche
bag one time,
but a funnier,
funnier one was when he and two of his
buddies who shall not be named,
we're out in the playground not too long
ago and there were sitting down in,
they're playing some game,
right?
It was recess and all the kids,
all the different grades are out there
running around.
And everybody knows my little kid,
you know,
mugsy he's like the mayor of the town.
He's,
he's just a jolly happy guy.
He's got,
he's got to,
he's going to be the guy that takes 10
years to get out of college.
Right.
And so he,
he and his two little buddies are
sitting there.
They're playing some game where they got
to count with their fingers.
So at one point,
Jack has the number one knee and he puts
up a finger,
right?
And one of the other kids starts
laughing and cause he's got an older
brother who told them what it means.
So he tells me what it means.
So they start shouting this out,
right?
And this word,
they start shouting and,
well,
a couple of the older kids walk by,
any here,
here,
these three kids,
six years old.
She's yelling this way,
laughing.
Uproariously cause they think it's the
funniest fucking thing they've ever
heard.
And so they get called into the
principal.
Well what happens next?
I have to find out about this,
right?
So now they notify the parents and you
know,
admittedly the principal's laughing when
they,
when they're telling you the story.
But now I have to have a conversation
with mugsy when,
when I come home.
So I come home and I said much anything
happened today?
And he goes,
Nah,
that didn't happen.
And me walked right by me and I said,
wait,
come back here.
I said,
did you get called into the principal's?
He goes,
oh yeah.
He said,
we were,
let me see.
We were playing on the playground and I
went like this.
And you know what this means?
I said,
no,
I don't need to know.
And I look out of the corner of my eye,
see his two older brothers,
like around the corner just waiting
because they know he's gonna get his ass
kicked right for,
for this.
And they're just like,
they can't wait.
And so I said,
don't,
I don't need to know what it is.
Just don't do it again.
Whatever you do,
don't do it again.
And he goes,
no,
no.
You got to know what this means.
He's really intent on it.
And so I said,
and he's two other boys skirts.
I go,
they're like,
oh,
he's going to get so.
And I said,
all right,
what does it mean?
And I had no idea what he was going to
say.
But what he did say was mother Fucker,
and that's what they were yelling on the
playground.
All three of them at the top of their
lungs Gel and no mother fuckers six
that's six years old.
That's a door.
And I started laughing and the two other
boys walked away,
disgusted that I was laughing.
And that's the end of my story.
So they're great kids.
So how do you take that gene?
You put it back in the bottle,
do you know?
You know,
you just say don't use it all starts
screaming motherfucker.
And there,
there's not much you can do.
Lee throwing their finger up in there.
It's hard to do.
I mean,
I find myself having to constantly catch
myself.
I'll,
I'll say,
you know,
things like,
you'll quit jackass and around and then
I'll think,
okay,
I probably shouldn't say that,
you know,
but,
but that's fine.
I can't get,
you know,
my dad was the guy I've ever known in my
life and he swore and I'd,
I'd,
uh,
it didn't scare me in any way.
Well,
I don't have a problem with it.
It's part of what I do for a living.
But when I was,
uh,
when I wa I was,
we were in,
we were skiing with my,
uh,
youngest daughter who was three and a,
we're packing up the stuff and she
forgot to pack her helmet and a helmet
wasn't packed and the thing,
and she looks down at her luggage.
She looks down at the helm and she goes,
Oh shit,
this is something adorable.
But she was three at the time,
about a three year old sage.
Let's see if you could get together with
mugsy.
Then she could have said Shit and you
could just say what happened?
And she just said,
I forgot my mother fucking helmet.
Then she's got a completely sentenced.
Gosh,
I mean,
there's something really cute about
kid's swearing.
It's just adorable.
We tried to tell him,
you know,
don't,
yeah,
we try to teach them the basics.
Don't swear.
If you can have,
the problem is they're going to,
it seems so attractive to do because
they're not supposed to do it.
And when no one's around,
like,
you know what I heard,
I remember I found a new word starts
with a C.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
no,
they're doing it.
Yeah.
That one
we learned everything we learned from
older brothers.
Right.
Or from friends who had older brothers
then talking.
But it was a,
it was a slower process.
Right.
Partly because we didn't have the
internet and all that crap.
Right.
And so I think of what you learned a
lot.
It took a little bit longer,
you know,
to learn.
Like,
I don't think I've really rolled out
douchebag till I was probably 12,
maybe 13.
Well,
we were talking yesterday,
right,
about,
um,
access to the Internet where kids see so
much more and hear so much more today.
Like there especially like violent
images and their access to terrible
things.
And there's just so much that if you
leave a kid alone with a computer or a
phone that's online,
oh yeah.
They're just going to find out
everything about the world way before
their little brains are ready.
No,
you can't do it.
You've got it.
You've gotta be,
you gotta lock it down.
Right.
I mean,
it's a good thing they got to learn the
technology,
unlike what I apparently what I
apparently did.
I'm gonna leave my,
my,
uh,
my watch here for you since I don't know
how to use it,
but a year are you gonna let them get
online?
Uh,
well,
they can do that.
They can do school research,
right?
They need to,
um,
they can like,
Eh,
the,
the middle one loves basketball.
He loves basketball so he can look up,
you know,
a steph curry videos,
things like that.
As long as they've got supervision.
Right,
right.
They have to have supervision.
You have to know what they're doing.
But if you're right,
cause if you let them have free rein at,
it's a freak zone out there and they'll
find it just by accident.
And you're right.
I think their minds,
I mean you can't ask kids to process all
the crap that's out there on the
internet at that,
at that early age.
It's not fair.
It's not right.
And you can't tell me that there's not
some correlation between,
uh,
access to all that imaging and violent
images and everything else.
And some of the problems that we have in
the world today when we ask,
how does that kid,
how does he go so far off rails of the
stills
are gone or it takes gun out of the
house and shoots up a place.
How does that happen?
And I can't,
I don't know.
I mean you,
I,
what do I,
again,
I'm not a,
I'm not a psychiatrist,
so people don't listen to me.
And take that as says medical advice,
but I know what you're saying.
I mean there's,
there's a reality of the world that we
live in and,
uh,
these,
these images,
the,
I mean,
you're,
you're not going to stop,
you're not going to change the world
that we live in by limiting the access
to these kids have to these things.
But it is strange how much access we
have to disturb me.
Gay images,
violence,
violent videos,
and there's just so your brain knows
that that's out there and that there's
just so many more examples of it to
watch if you were 12 years old or
whatever,
and,
and you know,
in the old days,
and maybe you found out where your dad
stored the playboys.
Yeah.
That was it.
In this case,
a cardboard box in the back,
a hall closet.
Uh,
then that was,
you know,
that was it.
But that was how,
I mean,
that's how you learned,
right.
I never saw,
I mean,
I saw a few altercations in my
neighborhood when I was growing up,
but like a,
like a,
a real violent encounter.
I never saw anything.
No,
no.
Shoot 'em up games now that we've got.
Um,
so we use that,
that xbox and I talked about it.
It's all sports games.
You can't,
uh,
the whole gears of war and call of duty
and all the rest of it.
No,
he can't.
He can't do that.
But then again,
you know,
your,
your kid will go out to his friends
house.
Yup.
The next thing you know,
have had exploded and I don't know.
So,
you know,
what are you doing?
You're right.
You can't protect him,
but you gotta you gotta do your best.
Um,
but the world's changing,
but it's changing faster than we realize
the impact they're more aware of in
regard to the impact that it has on
kids.
I just think it's changing for the
people that are adults.
Like,
wow,
the world's changing.
Yeah.
It's changing for that four year old
that's growing up in that world right
now.
And they're going to have,
the moment they get online,
they're going to,
it's going to go from,
I'm just a little kid,
live in my little kid.
That's what Mommy,
that's my daddy to whoop the big world
all in one big smash.
And I don't think anybody's a little
bit,
I don't think an adult's brain is
designed to handle most of the shit that
we have access to online.
No,
no,
forget about a growing mind.
And what influence that has on society
is really yet to be determined.
What are they doing to that donkey and
why?
Yeah.
And I'm actually get paid for that.
I know that was a career you could
engage in.
Uh,
no.
I,
it's,
it is.
I,
I've got,
like I said,
I've got a daughter.
I,
there's an interesting age difference.
Right?
So what is it that's about 1213 years
age difference.
Right.
And so I feel like I've,
there's a social thing there is,
you can study,
this is a case study.
W w what my daughter went through
growing up and access to information,
which was uniquely different than now,
even though you know,
she started,
there was really no internet or
anything,
but then it,
it exploded by the time she was
essentially a,
okay,
well the difference
between you and I who grew up with
nothing,
right?
No Internet.
And then it became the Internet when
we're fully formed and as an adult and
then you've got a chance to see it and
even then screwed it up and made
mistakes and got online within God
viruses on your computer and saw some
stuff he really didn't want to see.
Had that dial tone.
Remember yet,
dial in when you were gay
and then the picture would kind of come
in and little,
little blips.
Oh yeah.
You did really want to see it anymore.
Oh,
when was it?
When did you get first get a cell phone?
I got one real early.
I got a cell phone in the 80s wow.
Yeah.
Well it was a comedian and like 89 I
think.
I had a cell phone.
I had a cell phone in my car.
It was like permanently bolted down to
my car.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I got it.
Those so I could get,
the thing about it was I could get gigs
with it.
So like,
uh,
some people get ahold of you.
Yeah.
Like Bill Bloomin',
right.
Uh,
who was the owner of,
um,
the Wilbur Theater in Boston?
It was owner of the comedy connection
back then.
Always jokes around about it.
He was like,
you got a lot of words because you were
the only comedian with a cell phone.
Like,
so he could call me up and say,
hey,
you know,
this guy just got a flat tire on his way
to New Hampshire.
Can you do the Gig?
And I'm like,
fuck yeah,
I'm in.
I'm,
I'm there.
I'm know I'm already at my car cause
that's where my phone is.
Yeah.
How much did you have to pay for that
phone?
I don't remember.
I couldn't afford it.
No,
I remember not being able to pay for it
after a while.
Yeah.
It was just,
it was a dummy.
I always spent more money than I had.
I mean it's,
yeah.
I've never been good with finances.
I've never been frugal,
but he's just one of those things where
I realized that I could get it.
So I got it.
But you remember that status you'd have
to drive around if you,
before that,
before you had that,
that phone in your car,
you'd have to drive around.
I'm looking for a public payphone.
Oh yeah.
And you're getting your quarters right.
Or you had to have a calling card.
You remember those things?
He'd have a car did,
I would get,
I would get fake cards too.
He could buy them off people.
They were like,
like counterfeit cards and they were
good for a couple of days and they'd go
under,
I think you'd buy other ones.
And then there was other things you
could do.
You could take a sound device and put it
up to the phone and you could get a,
get a call with that.
Like you would put up this thing to the
voice box area and it would make noises
like,
yeah.
And it would somehow or another,
it should open up the,
uh,
yeah,
the line.
I remember that we are,
we used to before the,
yeah,
before the cell phone technology hit.
And this is early days of being with the
agency and when you were overseas,
if you were in an urban setting,
you spent half your time looking for
operating payphones.
Right.
You know what,
at some 34th world country,
you're trying to find a payphone that
actually works.
Cause you got to make some sort of,
you know,
call related to whatever operation
you're engaged in.
And you know,
the kids,
the kids today and the agency don't
understand that,
you know,
cause they've all got great technology
and mobile communications.
Uh,
yeah.
In the old days it was,
it didn't,
it didn't work that way.
Uh,
those are people that we know what a
phone booth is.
No,
I,
yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
Look about fights.
That's like a common expression.
These two could have fought in a phone
booth that could have fought fight,
can't even say it could have a fight in
a phone booth.
But today you say fight in a phone booth
and people go,
why don't just say they got a fight on
her fucking,
you know,
something else that doesn't exist
anymore.
A wine barrel.
This London,
you're London now and there's,
you know,
there's those iconic red phone booth.
You haven't met a phone in it.
There's a num work.
What are they now?
Just keep getting them up.
Yeah.
I think they kept him at,
you could probably find one
occasionally.
It's got a phone in it,
but it wasn't that long ago.
I remember they actually had functioning
phones.
You would go outside any seven 11 or
whatever.
And they were doing a bank of payphones.
I actually stopped and took a picture.
I was,
I forget where the hell are.
I said nowhere pulled into a gas
station.
It was,
I was pulling out after,
oddly enough,
getting gas and uh,
I looked over to the side and there was
a pay phone against the wall.
And then now that the receiver was just
dangling on the ground,
but I literally stopped,
got out and took a picture of it so I
could show my kids,
you know,
we used to make calls on these things.
This is how it worked.
I remember when there was no answering
machines.
You remember that?
Yeah.
And the first answer and machine,
whoever your buddy was a got the
answering machine first.
You thought,
man,
that's the deal.
That's so plush.
And I remember we got an answering
machine where you could call it,
and then when the dial tone went on,
you would punch in like a code and you
could listen to your messages and you
weren't even home.
You could retrieve those messages crazy.
You could call it the car to your
answering machine.
There's a funny,
uh,
yeah.
Okay.
Maybe you shouldn't.
I guess I,
what do I know?
But you should never start a story out
by saying there's a funny story.
There's a story that when Lyndon Johnson
was a,
was a president,
not president,
I take that back.
He was in the Senate and it was another
guy,
Dirksen.
It was a famous senator.
And so Johnson was,
uh,
one day he was,
he was driving,
Dirksen gets this call,
I think I got their guy,
right?
It gets a call from Johnson and they're
talking and Johnson say,
wow,
I got to talk to you about this thing.
He said,
Whoa,
hold on.
Oh,
hold on a second.
He says,
I gotta,
you know,
we're just pulling up outside the
building.
I got to get out.
I'll call you when I get to my office.
Dirksen says,
what are you,
where are you calling me now?
And he goes,
oh,
I got a phone in my car and Dirksen
hangs up and meet is this,
I gotta get one of those.
So this,
as the story goes,
uh,
pulled some strings there in the Senate,
got somebody to put a phone in his car,
right?
And so then he calls,
uh,
Johnson and he says,
Eh,
Linden,
I'm just calling you from,
from my car.
And Johnson says,
ah,
that's,
that's great.
Hold on a second.
I got a call coming in on the other
line.
Thanks up on him.
So,
Eh,
yeah.
Whether it's true or not,
it's an apocryphal story.
Phones in their car back then.
Well,
you know,
if you're a senator,
what year did they invent carphone's?
Uh,
uh,
Eh,
probably the year you got one.
No,
I don't,
I have no idea when they invited carf
ones.
But you know,
uh,
Jamie,
we should look in 1946 1946 what,
what?
Wait a minute.
1940 600 will come up.
Pimp you had to be in 1969 to pull up
and like a 69 corvette.
The fucking phone in your car or a
Lincoln town car.
Whoa.
This is what that's like.
[inaudible] is a mobile phone device
specifically designed to be fitting in
automobile.
That's what we should call him back
then.
Car phones.
Remember service originated with the
bell system and was first used in Saint
Louis.
June 17th,
1946.
Wow.
Before the fucking end of the war,
right?
Yeah.
No,
no,
no.
That was after the end of the war.
End.
45 okay.
Yeah.
So a year after the World War II,
that's an incredible phone in their car.
And more importantly,
why St Louis?
What was what that was going on in St
Louis?
It,
that's the site of the first car phone.
Wow.
It was a radio enthusiasts who had the
foresight to invent the annoying habit
of talking on the phone in the car.
So that basically worked on the radio
and it would somehow or another connect
to a regular phone line.
Is that what it worked?
Uh,
Jesus Christ.
Yeah.
This is way beyond my apple had this
look,
Johnson had it when he was in the
Senate.
Yep.
Yeah.
So and that would have been,
yeah.
What's that?
That's,
that would have been like 15 years after
this happened to her,
or 14 years after.
After they invented it in Saint Louis.
But,
but yeah,
I remember when they,
you know,
the mobile phone then was that big case
that we carry around and you had to get
out of your car is set out out on your
car and then it started getting it.
Yeah.
That'll be a big fucking thing.
You throw over your shoulder.
A big handle.
I got a big box at home full of all the
old phones that I've had over the years
and it's like if I could ever get myself
organized,
I would turn it into some sort of wall
art installation because it's cell
phones through the years,
at least covering the past few decades.
It's certainly interesting.
What do you got there?
Jamie?
First developed in 1920 mobile wireless
transmission device.
Send and receive messages in the 1920s
in 19 and 20 Jesus,
that guy behind him as the boss,
you can tell he's,
he's listening.
He's the guy in charge.
Man did it.
Did,
did.
Wow.
Yeah.
I think that would be a great idea to
show kids today that I'm that old brick
phone from Wall Street.
Fantastic to the member.
The,
was it called the Star Tech Startac.
I saw somebody's still using one of
those the other day.
Yeah,
the little flip flops.
A little flip phone with the little,
it was of would come out.
Yeah.
To be fair,
he did.
He had a Dork knob and then other
STARTAC.
There was a sweet phone.
I had one of those.
I was like,
oh baby.
It was like you want to use terms like
star trek,
right.
You were like Captain Kirk with that
thing.
He had flipped it open and you're
talking,
maybe you can get an extra fat battery
for it.
Although that didn't set so well in your
suit coat.
No,
it's terrible.
Those fat batteries,
but if you didn't have a fat battery you
can make a call for four minutes.
Battery Technology was terrible back
there.
That waterway fun by the way,
has an excellent battery.
It's got a great battery amp battery
that battery is doing.
It's sucking all the information out of
your system as you got it.
Yeah,
but sweet,
sweet signal that you get so long while
it does that.
It is true.
Go out there kids,
get yourself a quiet way back.
A phone.
Amazing cameras.
They have a 40 megapixel camera in one.
They make all sorts of white goods too,
you know like washers and dryers and
refrigerators.
So way does.
They're putting all that stuff in our
homes.
Yes it is.
Yeah.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't engage in any shenanigans in
my kitchen.
Not One of my fridges watching,
but I don't have a,
I don't have a hallway fridge.
I got a don't,
I have no idea what I have.
I have no idea what I've got.
We'll go,
we're about ready to start a,
and this is what actually,
what the viewers or the viewers,
the listeners have been waiting for is,
uh,
is to hear about my kitchen renovation.
What are you going to do?
Oh,
we're gonna renovate the kitchen,
put a pizza oven in.
Crazy.
We're going to put a big wine cooler.
I know that that was,
that was the only thing I was actually
concerned about with this.
The kitchen renovation,
boozing it up.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
every now and then it mostly Martinis,
but I,
nice glass of wine is nice like,
or glass of wine and so we'll get to,
we do this thing and I don't know,
they came over the other day and my
wife,
who's definitely outputted my coverage,
she has a lot smarter than I am and much
more organized and efficient,
but she wasn't there.
So the guys with the plans,
whatever they call them,
the planners,
they came over to show me the drawings
as if I care.
Right.
Or as if I could actually read these
drawings right there,
the blueprints for what they're going to
do,
the kitchen.
So I dutifully kind of page through them
and made a little notation on one.
I actually really did.
I just said,
look,
I at know star wars.
And so the guy says,
what are you thinking?
I said,
yeah,
let's go for it.
Let's do it.
I saw,
I approved it just by have no idea what
I've engaged in at this point,
but it's going to take about three
months and we're going to have ourselves
one hell of a kitchen so it won't be
done by the time you show up.
But uh,
so then you'd be eating off of one of
those fucking,
we're going to get,
we did the call while we had a,
we,
our kitchen get renovated and we had a
hot plate.
We're cooking off a hot plate,
but it was back in college,
lasted a while,
but it didn't let us appreciate the
kitchen.
And did you have kids at the time or,
yeah.
Okay.
Yeah.
Well it's kind of funny.
We were laughing about it.
We thought it was funny.
We get with our three,
uh,
yeah.
We'll probably just going to go up.
We've got this little place,
little cabin up in the up in that,
a great town of Mccall.
We'll just go cold 10 hang out for the
summer.
You've got a cabin up there too,
so we'll just,
uh,
we'll,
we'll stay up there and let them spend
their days fishing and swimming man's
dreams,
but somewhere get away.
Just spread it.
Every man of works too hard.
Just give me a cabin somewhere and work.
Just go,
ah,
I'm just getting into the car.
No one,
you're pointing the car towards the cab.
You could be sitting in traffic for two
hours,
but I'm going to the cabin and we get
to,
especially at cabin by the lake.
That's a dream.
It's a beautiful lake.
And have friends who have a house on
Coeur d'alene.
Oh yeah.
They took me,
they took a picture and a,
they're in a boat and you could see the
ground like 80 foot deep with a
photograph of the,
the,
the could see the bottom of the lake.
It's crazy.
It's like,
how is that possible?
That water's clear.
Then that's like Fiji water.
You've got a whole lake full of Fiji
water.
You should go off.
Well,
that's what we do.
Get an Idaho,
you know,
we've got money to burn a fucking crazy
though.
I mean it was so beautiful.
It's a,
it's a,
that is a,
that quarter lane area up.
It's northern part of the country.
Kootney county and it's a great people
up there.
Right?
Tiger Woods has a place up there.
I bet he does.
Yeah.
Banks,
chicks up there.
Crazy.
Yeah.
Some men.
Not Anymore.
He's focused on golf now.
Ah,
I think so.
I think he's,
I think he's given us everything except
golf.
I think that's why swimming,
that's how you have to do tiger.
Yeah.
I remember back when you were young and
ugly.
Well,
now you're Richard.
I believe back when you were,
you weren't wealthy,
you weren't doing as much of that.
Pictures are amazing.
That might be one of the most beautiful
spots in the country.
Yeah,
they've got a,
and it's,
it's just a great,
it's a great spot.
It takes about a,
well,
it's a hell of a drive to get up there
from Boise,
but you can fly to spokane,
Washington,
great town.
And uh,
it's only about a 30 minute drive from
spokane.
Is it really?
Yeah.
Wow.
Are you going up to spokane to do a show
or no?
Uh,
you should.
That's the move,
Huh?
Yeah.
What else are you going?
Are you going,
is this a one and done or you're in
trial?
I just did a Netflix special that I
film,
but it's not going to come out until
September.
And so now I'm just going to do a bunch
of gigs and get ready to put together
another hour.
Okay.
How long does that take?
It takes a while.
I might have to do some illegal
substances.
Don't tell,
don't tell anybody.
Now it's my ideas.
I won't say,
hold on a second.
I won't say anything to end yet.
This director designate trying to tell
all these folks to make mushrooms legal.
It's not hurting anybody and it's given
a lot of folks from real good ideas.
Oh,
hey,
before I forget,
and I probably should've told you this
offline,
but,
uh,
Newt Gingrich,
thinks it would be excellent to sit down
and talk to get the fuck Outta here.
Hits the truth.
Newt Gingrich Gingrich,
and I'll tell you how I know this.
How do you know this?
I know the person who runs his,
uh,
admin and operations is media stuff and
the things that he does,
and he does a lot.
Uh,
and she's a great person.
And she told me,
you know,
that's what he'd like.
She brought it up.
Then she brought it up to me,
the podcast.
Right.
That's what I know.
I fucked up and I got too big.
It's time to quit,
Jamie.
We've got to move to quarter lane.
Go Pike fishing.
They got some awesome pike fishing out
there.
Yeah.
Dot.
Yeah,
they do.
And good hunting up there too.
Um,
but it's,
uh,
so that's a great part of the country.
They look at it,
look,
oh yeah.
See Houses on our,
that's a precarious situation.
That's,
yeah.
You got to assume that just the tank
situation as well.
They're not hooked up to city water.
What a fucking weird spot in the house.
He greedy bitch.
Can you find the right to tell him the
rock?
Pay It like mccall.
I mean,
not since we're,
since today's travel log,
we're taking you to Idaho today.
How do you say it yet?
Pay Yet.
That's where you got a cabin.
I know,
right?
Oh.
How many people out there?
Uh,
not many.
It's a small town.
It's much smaller than catch him.
Like,
give me a number.
Uh,
Geez.
I don't already 17 white nationalists.
All right.
There's a lot of thinking about one of
the other states.
You not thinking it like,
oh no.
I know.
Some white nationalists.
What they say?
I've never met one,
but uh,
well they wouldn't,
I know they'd keep that from me as well.
This guy knows too many people.
That's really that Lake Shit I'm telling
you that makes me,
right now I'm getting anxiety.
I want to push the boat out there and
start fishing.
I can see the water,
like look how flat it is.
I could see like the,
the,
the trout breaking the surface during
the summer.
You just go out there and you know,
in the high season you don't,
when you're not fishing you just float
around.
You know,
the little water skiing if you want to,
but mostly just kinda hang out.
That looks fucking amazing.
And 10 minutes from there is a,
is the ski area at a ski resort.
It's a great little ski place,
man.
I think I'm done with skiing every time
I ski,
this is what I'm doing.
Don't get hurt.
Didn't get hurt.
Right.
Yeah.
I know another one of my friends just
blew out her acl.
I know three friends that blew out their
acl in a year.
All skiing,
all skiing.
Three in a year.
Yeah.
You gotta you gotta with just right.
It's like everything else you've got to
you,
but you're right.
Once you have that thought and I know
exactly what you're thinking,
I'm doing the same thing.
I'm heading down to stop thinking.
I can not afford to hurt myself.
I got too much work to do.
Don't get hurt,
don't get hurt,
didn't get hurt.
I was snowboarding one time and I just,
I just completely lost it.
A cracked some ribs,
couldn't catch my breath when I was
laying on my back and it was towards the
end of the day in which always that's
when it happens,
right?
You're exhausted but you think I'm going
to do one more run because it sounds
like a good idea.
And so anyway,
I'm laying down there and there was
nobody else out.
I mean it was,
it was getting twilight and I'm looking
up at the sky,
is this here?
This is this sound good at that.
And I hear this noise behind me and
these two guys,
it couldn't have been.
Both of them are probably like 19 maybe
they come,
they come screeching to a stop and I'm
looking up and I'm trying to catch my
breath and I can't really move.
And so all I can see is when their faces
come into the frame above my head and
they both looked down at me and they go,
ah,
dude.
And then they take off,
left you then left me there.
They didn't do it I guess,
cause I didn't say,
ah,
maybe,
maybe we'll paint it.
I
just,
I didn't say anything because I was
trying to catch my breath and they just
take off and I'm thinking,
well that's sucks a small window.
Say help.
Yeah.
Pride.
Ego.
Right.
You're like,
I don't want to tell these little fucks
that I'm hurt.
No,
exactly.
Little punks.
I dropped into a tree,
well a couple of seasons ago and um,
I was,
we were out on the well a tree.
Well and I was saying,
what's that country?
Well you know how you have a tree,
lots of snow falling,
you know,
you got powder.
And so what will happen sometimes is you
get the appearance of solid snow,
but around the tree,
the base of the tree,
you'll get these,
these little caves almost like it.
There's nothing around the bottom of the
tree.
So the tendency is for the snow.
If you get too close to the tree,
well,
you'll collapse into it and then you're
the bottom of this hole,
right?
And you're trying to get out.
And usually it happens,
you know,
when there's beautiful snow,
it's all powder and you can't get out.
So anyway,
uh,
my wife and I were on the backside of
this mountain,
and so there's nobody around.
She got out ahead of me.
Um,
and uh,
I fell into this thing and that's the
time when I thought to myself,
after about 35 minutes,
uh,
trying to haul my ass out of there,
I thought I could actually die here.
But the snow was falling lightly,
you know?
And there was still a little bit of sun
coming through and it was a beautiful
thing.
And I literally thought I had to lay
down for a minute to catch my breath and
think,
I'll give this another try.
I thought,
Eh,
there's worse places to die.
And I know he thought that.
I thought,
you know what,
if you got to go here,
because I'm thinking at some point my
heart's going to explode because I was,
I was working like a son of a bitch.
How are we trying to do it?
You just try it out first.
At first you think,
okay,
I get my,
get my skis back on and get out of here.
Or maybe I won't get my skis,
I'll,
I'll try to just step out of here and
get up.
But it's just all,
it's like being in a quicksand.
It's like being in quicksand,
I guess is a good analogy.
Yeah.
And so it's just that you can't get a
grip on anything.
You can't get ahold of anything and
you're trying to pull yourself back up.
And even if you do get a little ways
out,
you're on,
you're on powder,
right.
And this,
and there was a beautiful powder day,
right?
Blue skies is this powder.
Well,
you sink into it up to your thighs and
beyond.
And so when you're doing that,
think about it.
You're trying to,
you're trying to get,
cause then at a certain point you gotta
get your skis back on,
right,
right.
And then your,
your,
uh,
you're,
you're about,
you're about done.
By the time you get out of a tree.
Well,
and now you're trying to get your skis
back on and you're,
you're in powder and you're trying to do
that.
And it's,
I,
it turned into a real gogo,
but I,
I guess my point for you,
because it was a beautiful day and I
thought,
Eh,
not that I was going to lay down and
die,
but I thought if you had to,
if you happen to go,
it's not a bad place.
It's a great attitude.
But it's also,
I think indicative of how much shit
you've seen in your life.
God says this,
these,
I'm here.
I was worried about the wolves.
The wolves come by.
It not my bones would do.
They would like that guy's coyote.
Oh,
it was a horrible story about,
uh,
in Africa where a toddler got stolen by
a leopard.
I put it on my twitter.
Jeez.
I put that stuff on my twitter all the
time.
People go,
why do you put this up?
Why do you post this?
Because I want people to know.
I want you gotta delusional sense of
wildlife.
You fucks.
You dummies out there taking selfies
with bears.
Well,
I just,
I was in,
uh,
Connecticut just a a couple of days ago.
Um,
and I was talking to some folks there
that I know,
uh,
cause we used to live out there a while
back before we moved to Idaho and they
were telling me a story that they've got
this alert out.
This bobcat is on the loose in
Connecticut right now.
It's a pretty rural state.
People don't realize that.
Yeah,
it is,
but it's a rural state.
But anyway,
this,
this lady was walking her two little
dogs,
right.
I know what kind of dogs they were.
But this out of nowhere,
this bobcat just like swooped and
grabbed one of them took off.
Right.
And she's chasing the cat tried to save
her dog,
but that dog is done,
right.
Yeah.
And so she's trying to chase so she gets
anyway,
so they had sightings of this thing,
but now everybody's freaking out because
it's a danger to their,
their shit's zoo or whatever.
They found a mountain lion and
Connecticut a few years back and I think
he got killed on the highway,
I think,
uh,
and they found was driving.
Ah,
one of the things they fell out in this
sort of humor he outlined,
it was edited,
traveled from,
I want to say North Dakota.
It's way all the way across the country.
That's fantastic.
Yeah.
They can roam,
man.
Yeah.
It's like we used to have coyotes come
across our front yard and Connecticut.
Oh yeah.
I mean they're,
they're so adaptable.
They're in New York City now.
Really?
Yup.
That is not where I would go as a
coyote.
What does this all links in someone's
kitchen?
Oh,
that's not good.
That ain't good.
Wow.
We hear that noise.
It's making like if you whoa,
how it got there.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
So creepy.
I'll tell you what the noise is.
This thing is making,
I think that's a person taking the
video.
Don't,
you know,
I guess
I would punt that thing and do another
dimension.
Yeah,
no fucking question.
I will get it.
The omelette pan out.
If this is going down,
it's going down right now and I'm going
to choose.
Yeah.
That thing was crazy.
I mean,
you know,
they made that noise back.
Just one that was a lady taking the
video.
Let me hear that again.
Give me some volume.
I think that is the lady.
No,
that's,
that's the cat.
Fuck you cat.
That thing is there is something wrong
with that cat.
That cat's got an issue.
It's got a problem.
Yeah.
That's on meds.
That's uh,
that's opioids right there.
There's something going on.
Holly's yeah.
Well thank you for bringing that up.
Um,
but you're right.
They,
the,
the notion about what wildlife is like.
Yeah.
You know,
I mean,
if,
you know,
it's just it and it's that difference,
right?
It's a difference.
If you're living in New York City,
you've got this perspective about,
about it and it's all,
that's why I'm [inaudible] Kylie's have
made their way into New York City.
You're gonna start snatching dogs and
people are going to go,
hey,
they're not our friends.
They're not,
uh,
they're not like,
why Coyote?
We should.
We just need to,
we need to understand why they're upset.
Yeah.
We've encroached on their land.
Nope.
This is what they do.
What was the best hunting trip yet?
I'm curious.
My favorite to hunt his elk.
Elk?
Yeah,
because first of all,
because you get one elk and you get
hundreds of pounds of meat and I love
that.
Yeah,
it's delicious.
The only thing that's as delicious as
this axis,
deer access deer is pretty damn
delicious.
The thing about axis deer too is it's
one of the most ethical trips because
you have to kill them because they don't
have any natural predators at all.
And there's 20,000 of 'em on Lanai
alone.
Then there's the lor on Molokai.
They have them on Maui and there's no
predators,
so they literally have a responsibility
to kill them.
Otherwise they're going to face
starvation and disease and
overpopulation,
decimation of,
of plant life.
I mean,
they just eat everything in sight.
Do you have to get a separate license
for each island or how does that not,
no,
I think you get a Hawaii state license,
but the way it works in Lanai,
you can,
you could shoot 12 of them.
12,
12 that's how many they have,
which is crazy for deer.
Yeah.
I mean the most he ever hear is like two
bucks in some states and you know,
they're,
they're really have a lot of deers.
What do you end up with once you address
it?
Um,
I would say each one you're getting
around 50 plus pounds of meat.
They're about 200 pounds on the hoof.
Okay.
Yeah.
They look,
they look more delicate than that.
But you know,
now it's a fairly big animal.
They're heavy.
They're fast as fuck too.
And Yeah,
when they run and you're like,
whoa.
They mean they run like a,
it's,
it's like,
again,
it's like an African animal,
like a deer.
Yeah.
It's much faster than a regular deer
because it's like that white tail that
took off and that video weight quicker
than that.
They would be,
that guy was not exactly what he was
saying.
Both.
Yeah.
I wouldn't use him as the bar to set
this by.
Yeah,
he was like a light bulb that you have
to slap a couple of times to get it to
go on.
Uh,
so,
uh,
I had a follow up question to the deer.
Dammit.
This is what happens.
You get older,
I know that holy smokes and they start
getting up in the middle of the night to
go pee,
but you're,
you're out in this island.
This is this gorgeous island on the
Pacific Ocean with just beautiful views.
I mean it's just unbelievable.
Stunning.
And it's filled with these deer.
I mean they are everywhere on that
island.
That's the best thing about when it
comes down to it,
the hunting,
the fishing,
it's just being out there.
Sometimes you have to remember,
you have to stop.
And I mean like it even went fly
fishing.
Sometimes you get caught up and all of a
sudden you have to stop and you step
back and you kind of look around and
think,
oh yeah,
this makes sense.
I don't do enough fishing.
I fucking love fishing.
I've,
I've done fishing a few times recently
with my kids,
but it's ocean fishing where you're out
there trolling,
you know,
you're in a boat and you're pulling the
line.
It's not as fun casting like on a lake
is the best like top water bait or
something like that.
Yeah,
that's great for kids.
Kids love that
man.
I've started taking,
uh,
I've been lucky enough to be a part of
a,
an Alaskan fishing trip that happens
every year when you guys go for a
halibut salmon.
And I've actually got a picture of a
couple of the halibut to,
uh,
my boy,
cause now he's old enough I can bring
him with me.
And um,
and,
and so we go every year when it's a,
it's a group of guys,
you know,
this as maybe a 20 guys.
Um,
and he,
he hauls up this,
but this was his first time going,
right.
He's up in Alaska,
this beautiful place and he just,
it was just,
you could just tell it just snapped him.
Right.
He was just like,
oh my God.
The expansive at all.
Right.
It's just the size of this place.
And then you get out on the water and he
starts hauling up this thing and it's,
and it's this massive halibut and he
just like,
I couldn't even put two words together
and then you have to tell them it's got
to go back in the water cause it's,
it's not big enough.
Right.
So it's getting halibut's gotta be
either below or above a certain size
that the middle range has maximum for
breeding.
Yeah.
They get them too big.
They have to let them go.
Right.
If you get,
if you get them.
Um,
not,
I mean,
the big enough while I'm talking,
I'll,
I'll bring this photo up.
I don't know why I'm,
oh my phone's dead.
Nevermind.
Okay.
Really,
technology fails me again.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
the,
the prime space in between,
I forget what the cutoff is.
I think they have to be over 80,
80 something inches.
I'm sure somebody can dial it and tell
me,
Oh yeah.
And if it's not,
if it's not over that and it's,
it's a,
it's a little bit over that,
then you got to toss back in.
Cause there's still in prime fucking
time and they'd produced more babies for
that.
Yeah.
The really big ones.
So a buddy of mine got a huge one and
they cut the line on him.
Yeah.
They were saying it's too big.
We got to let it go.
And he was like,
what in the fuck?
Yeah,
no.
If it's big enough,
then they can.
But if you look at them and you think
that's gotta be big enough,
80 inches.
Yeah.
If I,
if,
if this damn thing was working,
I'd show this photo of,
of scooter with his,
his,
uh,
his hell,
but we'll plug it in and charge it then
fine.
I know.
It's like,
I didn't know whether he had electricity
here.
I need to.
We do.
Yeah.
That's how the lights are on.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
I don't know how things work in Idaho.
Yeah.
It's a little different than,
but if 80 oh look at that size of that
fucking thing.
Pounds.
That's a beautiful one.
There you go.
Just pretend.
Just pretend my,
uh,
one of those kids is my kid pretty much
said wow,
they're enormous.
But if they're bigger than that,
they probably have to let them go.
I mean,
if you get a fish,
like what happens is no,
but if you,
if you catch it,
one that say is about a,
I dunno,
a s eight inches smaller than that,
then you got to toss it back in.
So the point being is you'll look at
something and think,
wow,
this is definitely big enough catch.
And then you got to measure
it.
And if it's not over that 80 some odd
threshold,
you got to chuck it back in.
But when you talk about efficiency that
big,
you think there's no way I got to toss
this back in.
But you do.
It's just,
it's state law.
That's great.
Yeah.
How many,
what does 80 inches.
So that's six foot.
One and a half feet.
Six and a half feet.
Yeah.
Geez.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Crazy fucking fishman.
And you just haul this and you can
imagine what it's like wine.
Yeah,
yeah.
400 feet down maybe.
Right,
right.
Cause you're down towards the bottom and
you just kind of bang in the,
you know,
the bait down there on the bottom and
you it up a door to a castle.
It's like,
yeah,
look at this.
Wow.
And I mean halibut or delicious.
It's really good.
And so we ended up with kind of like
what you're talking about when you,
you know,
you're thinking about,
well,
what do you end up with?
Well I ended up with an entire freezer
just from one,
this one trip while entire freezer full
of,
of salmon and halibut.
It's pretty,
it's pretty taste.
And you get to do it in Alaska,
which is one of my favorite places to go
to.
Alaska is just crazy that we stole that
from the Russians for like 15 bucks.
How much to we get it for cheaper than
Manhattan,
I think.
Yeah,
I think it was.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
Alaska and yellowstone to places.
I tell people all the time,
you gotta go,
you gotta go the $7 million.
That's it.
That was in 1867.
So,
so,
okay.
In current dollars.
So it'd be like $2 million but Manhattan
was like 15 bucks.
Right.
How much of the,
they give the native Americans and then
people,
people were getting crazy written,
all these stolen,
they're stolen,
but apparently we paid the Russians
pretty well,
but we still,
we stole it from the $24 24 yeah,
but you have to remember it was
undeveloped at the time,
so I'm like Alaska,
sorry.
Alaska is still undeveloped years before
the Russians must be.
They sold that to us for 7 million.
It is so big.
I mean at least Manhattan,
it's a fairly small,
but think about the Louisiana purchase,
right?
I don't think White Jefferson getting
that from Napoleon and I mean what that
was like,
and it is crazy when you think how this
nation was cobbled together in the
foresight that talk the and the sort of
the just the balls of saying,
yeah,
we're going to take that.
Thank you.
Okay.
15 million.
Approximately 4 cents an acre.
It seems like a fair price.
Shit.
It was purchased in a purchase treaty by
the Senate and October 20th of 1803
doubled the size of the United States
and opened up the continent to its
westward expansion.
Yeah.
Holy Shit.
First thing they did was encourage
people move out there.
You've got to populate that place.
Right.
That was the whole plan.
Well one of the things that we saw when
we were in Montana for the first time,
uh,
on the,
on the Missouri was you would saw these
homesteads where people tried to make it
out there and they realize you can't
grow anything out there.
Cause you know that Mudd,
it's just,
yeah,
it's not,
you can't til it,
you're not going to grow anything in it.
Whatever's growing there is what grows
there and you're not going to grow
anything extra.
You can't have a farm there.
And people tried forever because they
just thought,
let me just find some ground and all you
gotta do is live there for a certain
amount of time that would be yours.
But there's these really old broken down
houses from,
you know,
the 1,817 hundreds whenever people were
out there and you could still go there
and touch the wood.
It's really weird.
You can still see,
yeah,
there's this homesteads like that out in
Idaho and,
and uh,
it is crazy when you think about people
making their way across,
right?
We talked about how people are getting
softer,
right?
Oh well that's why when people,
you know,
you'll see photos of people from those
days,
hey,
they look hard,
right?
Yeah.
I mean they puff life skinny faces.
And just,
you know,
they don't often look happy,
but it's,
you know,
they were,
they were living a hard life and they're
making their way across the country and
sometimes you,
you imagine they just thinking,
ah,
fuck it,
this is as far as I can go.
And they just put up stakes there,
right.
They said,
fine,
we'll just build here.
And maybe it was good land.
Maybe it wasn't.
But can you imagine when you get to that
point where you suddenly staring at the
rockies and you think,
really,
I got to cross this in those days?
I mean it,
it,
the,
the expansion there,
the western movement of people.
Um,
there was a series called a
misogynistic,
but it was called the men who built
America.
Right.
Or the men who the frontiers men or
something like that is misogynist,
sexist.
I know exact women didn't build anything
you asshole.
I mean,
you know,
I did some cooking and uh,
yeah,
mending babies,
mending.
But no,
if,
if that series was really good,
there was a first one was the men who
built America and then they did another
series about the frontiersman.
And that ones is the one I'm thinking of
is,
I think there's like,
I don't five or six episodes to it.
I think it's on Netflix.
Uh,
but it talks about,
and it goes,
it covers the whole thing here.
But it covers Davy,
Crockett,
Daniel Boone,
all the characters that you remember
hearing about it.
But it goes into real historical detail
about it.
And it's,
it's fascinating when you,
when you look at how this place was
cobbled together and quickly and
quickly,
you think about just a couple of hundred
years time and relation to the rest of
the world.
A couple of hundred years,
things didn't change that much at all.
No,
exactly.
It remarkable story.
But uh,
but yeah,
it's,
it's also you get an appreciation for
kind of how we,
how we might have treated the native
Americans.
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
A seven year old came home the other day
with a pail look in her face and I go,
what's going on?
She's like,
I learned about the Donner Party today.
Hope fucking seven teaching kids about
the Donner Party.
She's like,
where are they die?
I'm like,
the mountains.
They tried to make it across during the
winter and they didn't make it and
choose it.
Like,
like they ate each other,
they ate each other.
Like they're teaching my fucking seven
year old that people eat people.
You're playing Oregon trail back then,
which is,
I mean,
it's a video game.
That's the video game violence.
But you know,
just,
just something about learning that that
could happen.
I mean,
and did just a couple of hundred years
ago,
not that long ago.
Well,
you look at Lewis and Clark,
look at what they did and what they were
wandering out into,
which they had no idea what they would,
they didn't know what the fuck was out
there in terms of predators,
terms of natives.
They didn't know what was going on.
I had to call one time from a production
company,
want to know whether I wanted to take
part in that and they wouldn't do a
series on it was on the Donner party.
They,
we're going to recreate that whole
expedition.
Right.
And,
or I mean,
right down to the last thing,
everything was supposed to be
historically accurate and everything.
And I,
I,
I listened to what they were doing and I
thought to myself,
thank you very much.
Uh,
I just,
I couldn't get myself excited about it,
I guess.
You know,
I thought it would be interesting,
but probably only interesting for the
first couple of days.
And then you're thinking,
ah,
why am I here?
Why am I here?
Right.
Yeah.
I mean for the sake of a show.
But you know,
I think they've,
they pulled it together.
I said I'd have to look and see what
they're actually faked a bunch of shit.
Anyway,
those shows things don't go well like
Tom Defrank it.
Yeah.
Because the crew is always right there.
Right.
It's like bear grylls will I survive why
you might eat and hopefully your
cameraman does do so bear grylls.
It was a direct response to survivor man
refusing to fake things cause he did it
on the same network.
Oh Les Stroud is a friend of mine and he
was telling me what happened.
They were trying to get him to fake
things and he was like,
no,
I'm going to go by myself with just
cameras and I'm going to fill myself
actually surviving.
And if you watch less,
he'll do a show where,
you know,
he's out there for five,
six days.
By the end of those five days,
his cheeks are sunken in.
He looks like shit.
He's barely sleeping.
He's just eating.
Anything you can find sometimes not
eating for days.
Well,
you know,
that'd be great.
Yeah.
Bear gcs.
He's all good in the Marietta is exactly
what's going to say.
Well,
I felt bottled water.
Now I'm off to the days inn on camera.
He's drinking his own piss and just
survival for roots soon as the camera's
like God,
give me that twinkie.
I don't remember where he came out of,
I can't remember what,
uh,
where he was in the British military.
Um,
I'm trying to remember.
I don't think he was with the sps or sas
or anything like that.
I think I thought it was,
I thought it wasn't a cs and thought
that's what they said.
Maybe it was maybe,
but anyway.
Yeah.
But yeah,
if you're doing it for real and you
think about the amount of calories
you're burning,
what you need to replace and then you
realize that's what it was all about.
People spent every waking hour,
uh,
collecting food and water to keep
themselves going.
Yeah.
That was it.
Until you know,
whenever you have thoughts that when you
go on hunting trips,
like if you had to just hunt for
survival,
a hunting trip,
you could easily go five,
six days and not even see an animal if
you're in the wrong spot,
you've got to try to find them.
I mean there's many days where you go
and you don't see anything.
Like what if you're hungry that day?
Well,
tough shit up shit.
Yeah.
And those people did that with muskets
and bows and arrows and tried to make it
across the country without any idea what
the fuck was in front of them.
I mean,
Lewis and Clark grind or Powell going
down the Colorado,
the amount of food they needed to
consume as an expedition.
Right.
It was astounding.
And
that the time that you had to spend
hunting and,
and,
and ensuring that you would keep
everybody fed and Lewis and Clark,
they ran out of food at a certain point.
They were reading their leftover candles
basically made out of a what?
Beef Tallow.
So,
um,
yeah,
that was it.
They were down.
That was it handles.
Yeah.
That's all they are hungry.
You have to be to eat a candle who gets
the wick.
It's Julie Delicious,
uh,
anything to fill your stomach.
I'm sure.
Yeah.
But,
eh,
anyway.
Um,
so that's,
I,
you know,
the interesting thing is if you live in
a place,
like if you live out west,
you're surrounded by this all the time.
You think about it for some reason.
I have no idea why,
but,
um,
it's,
I,
I get,
I've lived all over hell and back.
I'm never moving.
I'm never moving again.
It's obviously a gorgeous place where
you live.
I get it.
And Fuck Connecticut.
You went from Connecticut to there.
I did.
Yeah.
You went from one of the places that I
would never live to one of the places
that I would definitely live,
one of the world's,
one of the country's worst managed
states.
You know,
it's just incredible that New Jersey
obviously,
uh,
you know,
they just,
uh,
underfunded pensions are unfunded
pensions and a shitload of lyme disease
too.
Oh yeah.
Have you ever had lyme disease?
No.
It's not good,
John.
It.
Some people get it and they keep it.
Yeah.
That,
hold on it.
Yeah.
It's like dysentery or malaria.
It's just kind of sits within.
Yeah.
I uh,
I came down with this,
uh,
it was like flu,
like conditions.
People are fascinating.
I hope Mike tells us about his lyme
disease story and you just feel like
absolute shit.
It feels like a bad flu.
And so I would go and I talked to a
couple of doctors there in Connecticut
and they were like,
ah,
I think it's a flow.
Right.
And they couldn't,
they didn't diagnose it.
So then we go out,
we're out in Idaho.
We hadn't moved out there yet,
but we went skiing and we were in
Ketchum and I go into a clinic because I
said it just not feeling any better,
it just gives this thing as this
lingering.
So I go into a clinic there and I talked
to the guy and it's a young,
a doctor not too long out of medical
school and he says,
where,
you know,
where do you live?
I said,
Connecticut.
And he goes,
you got lyme disease.
I mean,
I know it diagnose lyme disease.
Turns out he went to this medical school
and Yale in Connecticut and he figured
out and so yeah,
it's pretty bad to go to,
I know to get a good doctor.
That's what your,
that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
We're 43rd and education,
but we are tops in healthcare.
So there ya go.
Uh,
yeah.
It's uh,
yeah,
but,
but ticks sees it.
It's gonna be a bad tick season at west
too,
because we didn't get really a big
freeze in parts of it.
Not,
not all over are creepy little animals.
They carry such debilitating diseases.
If you're heard about the lone star
tick,
the lone star tick that turns people,
uh,
they,
there's a certain derivative of a,
one of those diseases that comes with
this lone star tick that,
uh,
it attack something called the Alpha
Gow,
uh,
which is short for something else.
But it essentially makes you allergic to
red meat.
No,
yes.
Yeah.
There's a tick that if it bites you,
if it give you a disease,
it will make you allergic to red meat.
And it's spreading all throughout Texas.
Texas has a great a bunch of cases of
it.
There it is.
Texting me the size of a poppy seed.
Can you spot all five ticks in this
photo?
And then they are they well equipped
right there in the center?
Yeah.
Oh fuck.
What kind of nonsense is that?
That's the seat
he seen.
They just tweeted this out.
Why did you learn how to prevent tick
bites to go?
Got Grossed out?
Yeah.
Like don't eat them offline.
If you avoid muffins,
you won't get tick ticks on the muffins.
You asshole.
You did it on purpose for a picture you
ruined in food.
Yeah.
Um,
they scare the shit out of me.
Those little creepy bugs.
Okay.
Yeah,
we,
uh,
you know,
we,
we got a big old,
a English golden retriever,
so we're always,
you know,
during this time of year we're always
pulling ticks off him or he'll come
inside and sit down.
Next thing you know,
once crawling off of him and I,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's not,
it's not good.
But,
uh,
where'd you get you,
so you got lyme in Connecticut,
right?
Yeah.
A lot of people in the east coast to
getting it.
Yeah,
super common.
It's all but Connecticut is covered in
ticks.
I mean,
I had no idea when we moved there,
but we had a,
we had a nice sell property and we
haven't big pond out there and a little
stream running through.
It was very picturesque,
but it was also just covered in ticks
that we can do about that.
Nothing.
Right.
Yeah.
You know,
they'll go through and spray.
Uh,
but then you've got a part we can't let
the kids out.
Yeah.
Right.
What the fuck is the spray killing
besides the tech?
Right,
exactly.
Yeah.
So we don't,
we don't,
we don't do anything like that out
there.
Um,
and it's not,
it's not so bad out west,
but they still have it and they don't
have,
they don't have the,
the,
uh,
the same type.
So they certainly don't have this red
meat tick.
I had never heard.
That's a new one at Stetson.
That's a creep show right there.
The discovered it within the last five
years.
Yeah.
That wouldn't be good.
I mean,
I've given up a lot of red meat,
but now I'm not going to give up.
Right.
Don't threaten me.
You know what I mean?
I eat less than I used to eat it all.
He did all the talking monsters.
I try to,
I try to cut back to some degree.
Wow.
Eh,
you know,
just for,
you get a little bit older and a,
I'm trying to watch,
I got a family history of heart disease,
massive problem with heart disease.
My parents went um,
uh,
both uh,
that way one of my brothers has a
defibrillator and others got uh,
uh,
several stents.
The others on heart medication.
I mean it's just like,
it's part,
so it's a family thing so you can try to
do what you can,
but I'm not giving it up just like I'm
not giving up my Martini.
Are you kidding me?
I really don't believe that red meat has
any effect on that.
I think it's processed carbohydrates and
sugar.
I think that's what it's all about.
And this comes from conversations with
real scientists and nutritionists and
people understand the actual studies
data there.
There is an issue combining
carbohydrates and simple refined
carbohydrates with red meat,
saturated fats by themselves,
not an issue.
Saturated fats with high levels of
carbohydrates.
Definitely an issue.
Why?
I just say interaction.
See the interaction between the two of
them.
The Way Doctor Rhonda,
Patrick talked about it.
I could get ahold of her and tried to
get her to do it again and explain it to
me,
but it's the interaction between
saturated fats and carbohydrates.
It's not saturated fats on themselves on
their own saturated fat like red meat
and and Oregon meat in particular,
extremely healthy for you,
very good for you,
but we're so it's so you.
People are so used to consuming sugar
and simple carbohydrates and processed
foods for fuel that your,
your body just gets accustomed to it.
When you add saturated fat to process
carbohydrates and sugar,
that's when you become desperate when
get issues.
That's why a lot of these studies that
show that you know,
red meat increases heart disease.
If people eat red meat over four or five
times a week,
have higher instances of heart disease,
but they're not asking what are they
eating with the rich or the eating it in
a burger or they're eating it with fries
and shakes and because that's different
than eating a grass fed steak with
avocado and maybe a salad that's not bad
for you at all.
Yeah,
it's an look if cancer,
if red meat really gave people heart
disease and cancer and all these things
that people say there'd be no people.
Okay.
Because people have been eating red meat
from the beginning of time and literally
97% of the population eats me.
But people process this stuff
differently.
Exactly.
Yeah.
I try.
It's processing all the different
preservatives that people put on in in
red meat and processed foods.
That's what's fucking people up.
That and refined sugars and
carbohydrates do pay attention to
cholesterol issues.
I mean like is that something,
not dietary cholesterol,
but neither does American heart
association.
You know they even weightwatchers now
says that dietary cholesterol has no
impact on your actual,
like your actual blood cholesterol.
Weight watchers lets you eat as many
eggs as you want.
Eggs have a zero point system in
weightwatchers now.
Exos zero points.
Yeah,
I've been doing that egg white thing.
Everybody their whole life whites are
not good.
But the good part is the oak.
You want the egg and the yolk together.
Proteins in the white,
right?
I mean no protein in the yolk too.
They both have protein.
This is nonsense.
But the cholesterol is in the,
in the Yolk in the yellow.
But it's not bad for your cholesterol is
the building block for hormones?
Yeah,
I mean it's just we get lied to from the
beginning of time when it comes to,
well first of all there's a lack of
understanding and then there's also the
studies that come out that are fucking
funded by the sugar industry,
you know,
about that or the sugar industry paid
scientists to take the blame off of
sugar and put it on to saturated fat.
There was a whole New York Times article
about it.
The sugar industry bribed scientist to
lie about the dangers of sugar is,
uh,
what's the difference between,
I didn't even know what you'd call it.
Refined sugar and beet sugar is there,
Sarah,
there's difference in,
there's different sugars have a
different effect on like they have a
lower glycemic index and and really
usually is dependent upon whether or not
they're connected to fiber.
Like sugar in the form of fruit is not
bad for you.
Like if you eat an apple,
it's connected to fiber that the,
you know,
you're eating the whole fruit.
That's what it's supposed to be.
That's how it's supposed to be consumed.
The real issue comes when you take that
sugar out of that fruit,
you know,
whether it's high fructose corn syrup or
whatever the fuck y'all else you're
getting sugar from,
and then consume that sugar because then
it's sugar free of all the natural
things that contain it.
Yeah.
Fiber and the actual,
you know,
the tissue,
the,
you know,
the actual fruit itself,
the,
the tissue of the fruit.
Well was the thing I said,
well,
we tried to keep processed foods out of
the house for the most part,
right?
So we try to keep the kids eating
healthy and all the things we're
supposed to do.
But it is interesting the sense that,
you know,
from an economic standpoint,
right.
Eating healthy,
um,
there's,
uh,
you know,
you were advantaged if you're middle
class or upper class,
right?
If you're,
uh,
if you don't have the financial
wherewithal,
I think that's,
I don't know,
maybe I'm just blowing smoke up my ass,
but I think that there is something to
be said for that.
I mean,
cause if you're going and you're
thinking I'm going to eat organic and
I'm gonna eat all these expensive,
it's expensive.
Yeah.
And so,
okay,
well,
so you've got a group of people that are
disadvantaged in the nutrition side of
things because they ended up defaulting
to the process foods or the fast foods.
But I'm happy to hear about the red
meat.
Now,
you know,
I'm going to walk out of here.
I'm going to say I can eat a steak
whenever I want and then I'm going to
get bit by this tick.
I'm like,
I want to stay.
Well,
salmon is fantastic for that.
It's 100% true.
Yeah.
And the,
the essential fatty acids and salmon,
a mega fatty acids.
Salmon is just one of the best things
you can eat.
Wild Salmon.
Oh my God.
Phenomenal for ya'll.
And then we've got a freezer full u haul
in some king salmon and a beautiful,
fantastic.
It's so good.
And then,
yeah,
and that's the best meal,
you know,
is,
is that,
and some,
some basic vegetables and boom,
and you're done.
And Luckily I,
you know,
we're lucky our kids like fish,
they really like fishing.
You know,
there are a lot of their friends,
they'll come over for dinner.
I don't want fish was a little fucks.
Yeah.
I'm not gonna have that,
you know,
and they want a burger.
Okay,
fine.
But uh,
yeah,
we,
uh,
we had a ton of fish because you catch a
lot of fish.
So yeah,
it's really good.
Kids get really addicted to bread to get
really addicted to hamburgers and
sandwiches and things with the carbs.
It's,
it's about carbs with kids and you know,
you need a certain amount of carbs for
sure.
But we way too much.
Yeah.
In general.
And that is most likely what's
responsible for heart disease.
Most likely was responsible for the
overweight epidemic in America.
It's carbs.
Yeah.
I can believe that.
I,
I do think that the people,
people react differently.
So I should look at two people.
We've got the same diet.
I'm going to process it one way and I'm
going to end up with very high problem.
But,
uh,
yeah.
So anyway,
but bottom line is,
you know,
you get to a certain point and you start
thinking,
now I'm going to pay a little more
attention.
So that's where I am in life.
I'm paying a little more attention to
what I'm eating.
I'll pay a little more attention to my
regimen as far as you want to do for,
you know,
I'm going to send you some podcasts to
listen to.
That would be good.
Give you a real understanding of the
actual science behind food versus the
misconceptions and versus the
misinformation because there's so much
of it out there.
And then there's so much,
uh,
you know,
we've talked about this before.
This is probably a good thing to talk
about this now and I need to know what's
true and what's not true.
You remember when we talked about how,
uh,
the guy who started the atkins diet died
and he was 258 pounds and all that?
Well,
apparently when he fell and hit his
head,
he had,
he had serious problems in the hospital
and gained somewhere around 50 pounds
while he was in the hospital.
Even more than 50 pounds.
I believe he has 195 pounds.
They're saying when he was checked into
the hospital and his heart disease had
nothing to do with his diet,
it was a viral illness that caused his
heart to,
to fail.
And this was all related to organ
failure.
He had massive organ failure and a
massive,
a water retention.
What,
because of his body was falling apart
while he was in the hospital.
So what's,
what's the,
I mean,
most people think he died.
How well most people think he died
falling and hitting his head,
which is true,
but the Vegan propaganda was that he
actually died of a heart attack and that
he had,
uh,
he had was 258 pounds when he died.
So his,
his diet didn't work.
And,
but they're saying that no one,
he was checked into the hospital after
he hit his head.
He was only 195 pounds.
Okay.
So all of this weight gain that they're
attributing to his diet,
they're,
they're being disingenuous and
untruthful.
Yeah.
First thing you do when you check into a
hospital because you got to check
yourself out as quickly as possible.
Well,
this guy,
you mean when you checked into the
hospital,
he was fucked.
Apparently mean he fell and cracked his
head open on the ice and you know,
he wasn't a good scene.
And he was an older gentleman when it
happened.
I believe he was in his seventies okay.
And,
but he died.
He had massive organ failure and it was,
so somebody sent me something yesterday
about it so that whatever is heart
disease was,
it was not from like hardening of the
arteries,
from cholesterol,
from eating all that food.
Yes.
It's so hard to understand what's right
and what's wrong too because people get
so ideological about it,
especially vegans,
you know,
and you know,
and the,
and even some meat eaters get
ideological about it and they just,
people aren't looking at the real
relationship between food and health.
Well,
we got a few people in my family who are
Vegan and yeah,
it's a,
it's a little religion,
right?
I mean,
they're wonderful people.
They're great people.
But,
but I,
when it comes to this,
it's a little bit of a religious thing
for them.
And I'm staff like ideological.
Yeah.
They,
they want to think there's only one way
and that's to be plant based.
It cures all diseases.
It,
right.
Fix it.
Well,
I know I've had people that have gone
Vegan and they got sick and they had bad
blood work and Sam Harris is one of
them.
He tried it for a little while.
I tried to for quite a while and he did
it the right way and he just,
he got ill from it.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I'm a big fan of moderation,
moderation and everything.
Right.
I mean just,
yeah.
That,
that seems to be a reasonable attitude I
think in terms of when it comes to your
diet.
Right.
And just,
or a,
yeah.
You know,
it's,
I try not to overthink anything in,
uh,
in life and we,
we just,
you know,
we're in that point in society where
maybe because it is,
things are easy and we have made it easy
because of technology and everything
else that we were able to just analyze
everything to fucking fair.
They will.
Right.
So I'm just thinking maybe it's not that
complicated.
You know,
just,
you know,
you work out,
you burn more than you take in,
you know,
you try to eat healthy,
you stick to the basics,
you know,
grains and fruits and vegetables and
meeting granted a fucking terrible for
you.
Really?
See,
I didn't know that.
I always say grains.
Somebody told me grains.
Grains are not good for you.
Most grains are bullshit.
You're just,
it's just carbohydrates.
High nuts and seeds.
How about nuts?
Vegetables?
Not so great.
All right.
Seeds are great vegetables.
Almonds,
almonds are fantastic.
See I eat a ton of almonds.
Yeah,
look at that stuff.
I know I need calories to,
yeah,
there you go.
They are good calories.
Healthy fats are,
we used to,
there were times when if you,
if we're traveling or whatever and you
were sitting in some safe out somewhere
and uh,
it just waiting for something to happen
or just happened to be holed up for
whatever reason.
And there was like nothing in there.
Right.
I mean,
I remember times when I would eat
oatmeal,
that was all I would eat.
Cause that's all it was available.
And you'd eat oatmeal for like three
weeks in a row,
just,
you know,
because you were waiting to get on the
road and move and you'd had an access to
other foods,
you know,
think of,
wow,
that's a lot of oatmeal or something.
Right.
And so I developed,
when I was younger,
I'd developed sort of this attitude.
It's just fuel,
just,
you know,
keep moving forward so you've got to eat
something.
And so for a long time I didn't really
put much stock in a,
it tastes great or it's,
you know,
it's,
it's really good.
It was just more,
you know,
got to consume something to keep moving
and,
you know,
and so it's only,
it hasn't been,
it's been recent one.
I've really got to get focused on it.
You know,
what do you have to do to you when
you've got little kids?
You know what it's like,
you want to stick around,
right.
So,
um,
I'm going to send you some podcasts.
Yeah.
Do you cook?
I do.
I,
oddly enough,
I like to cook now.
I live well,
you know,
most people would assume if I can't
operate my watch that I can't turn the
stove on.
Uh,
but I can do that.
And,
and I find it actually a lot of fun.
You know,
it is,
and it's stress relieving.
It's very satisfying to sit down to a
meal that you prepared yourself,
especially if you grow your own
vegetables and pull them out of the
garden,
which we do.
My wife has a great little vegetable
garden and,
uh,
so we do that.
We have a few fruit trees and so that's
nice.
Yeah,
it's good.
It's good.
But it's,
the whole process is nice.
And I'm very,
uh,
I'm one of those people,
I think as two types of people,
you're cooking,
you've got a big mess all around you or
your cooking,
you clean up as you're cooking.
Right.
And so we were casting,
I'm the one that guy,
I like things to be the way they're
supposed to be.
I like to clean up or while I'm doing
things right.
So,
yeah.
So it's,
it's um,
that the rest,
uh,
yeah,
my and my kid said actually the two
older boys state they'd taken part in
it.
Now they'd like to grill,
you know,
and what's grilling is grilling bad for
you or good for grilling is good.
Okay.
I was afraid you were gonna tell me you
shouldn't grill meat grilling.
Okay.
Right.
Okay,
good.
Cause that's what we do basically with
that.
We got a big hundred thousand btus
outside and we just fire that up.
Um,
but yeah,
it's,
you know,
I,
there's nothing more,
so when you pull a fish out,
whether it's the ocean or the river,
you know,
and then that's what you're eating at
night.
It's the best it is.
Especially if you could do it that day
at camp fire.
Like if you get it right by the,
bring a skillet,
cook a trout right there on the beach.
Oh,
trout for breakfast.
It's amazing of legs,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I know.
Well it's,
but that,
there's something about it.
People always say,
Oh really?
You got to fish in the morning?
That sounds odd,
but you're up there early.
You know the sun's coming up.
You catch Califia Yankee out.
People still go with what you eat in the
morning.
Yeah.
Just like what?
You should always have cereal in the
morning.
What does that mean?
Well,
shit,
food.
It's food.
You should have food whenever you want
the food.
If you want to have a stake in the
morning.
There's nothing wrong with that.
I remember when I was,
when I was a kid,
that was,
I was back in the days when you know
boxed cereals,
you know that's what you ate.
The sugar pops.
They didn't even make it.
They didn't hide it.
Right.
It was like [inaudible] name,
sugar pops,
super super sugar crisp sugar smacks.
Yeah.
That the current time of air.
Yeah,
that's fantastic.
And as a kid,
you could go go through an entire box in
one morning before you went out and
played baseball.
Listen to me,
I saw you wrote a cracked up on sugars,
one around the eyes,
bugging out your pupils.
Dilated Mike Baker.
He's a pledge or talk.
Hey man,
listen.
Thank you very much.
Just flew by.
Good Dad.
That's why your phone's dead.
I'll see what boise man sounds good,
brother.
Thank you.
Thanks.
What happened.